what's up everyone this is anthony pop
leone Oh most of you know me as pomp
you're listening to off-the-chain simply
the best podcasting crypto let's kick
this thing off the following
conversation is with Mark usko the
founder and CEO of Morgan Creek Capital
Management and one of my two partners at
Morgan Creek digital in this
conversation we cover a lot including
his background what it is like to run a
university endowment the Morgan Creek
founding story how institutional
investors think about portfolio
construction how demographics affect
financial asset performance why
inflation steals wealth from the poor
how banks take control of your money
when you deposit it the best advice he's
ever gotten why governments help
companies manipulate their stock prices
what the benefits of Bitcoin are to
institutional investors and where he
expects Bitcoin to go in the future I
really enjoyed this conversation and I
hope you enjoyed the hundred and
fiftieth episode of off the chain skirt
school I want to know who has the best
URL crypto com
that's right crypto comm there crypto
platform with one goal mother and mass
adoption that's why we're all here we're
trying to get crypto in every wallet
crypto comm is helping people do that
through buying earning lending and card
payment everything you could want at
crypto comm go help your boy out tell
them pom sent you download the app or
visit crypto calm palms got you always
everyone to get into mining and didn't
know how don't worry your boy pops
gotcha everybody got some electricity
and Wi-Fi all you got to do is go to
coin mine comm you buy a coin mine it's
like an Xbox or a Playstation that helps
you turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mind
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mine comm tell them tom sent
you and thank me later
anthony pomp leon o is a partner at
Morgan Creek digital all opinions
expressed by pomp or his guests on this
podcast are solely their opinions and do
not reflect the opinions of Mourne Creek
digital or Morgan Creek Capital
Management you should not treat any
opinion expressed by pomp as a specific
inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only all right
guys bang-bang
this is one of two one-year anniversary
episodes that we're gonna record I'm
cheating and I've brought one of my
partners Marquess go in for this episode
the other episode is with Jason Williams
our third partner and mark and I are
gonna sit here and pretty much talk
about everything that we talked about
every day and you guys will all see the
intellectual horsepower that he brings
and hopefully by the end of this this
becomes one of the most popular episodes
that we've ever recorded so thank you so
much for coming and doing this no thanks
for having me I am beyond excited and he
scared me this morning when he said that
he's bringing questions as well so we'll
avoid those all right so I know you but
a lot of people listening might not
let's start with your personal
background and kind of what you did pre
Morgan Creek yeah yeah I will go back to
go forward I guess I always said I don't
do short well so good thing we got a lot
of time but how far back do you want to
go so I'll go all the way back yeah I
grew up on the left coast grew up in
Seattle Washington left there a long
time ago but that's where I grew up
moved around a lot in high school went
to three high schools hated my parents I
have this and everybody yeah exactly but
think about I went from Seattle
Washington hair down to my shoulders and
bell-bottoms to Weston Connecticut had
cut my hair and wear corduroys to
Houston Texas had to get a cowboy hat
oh the rodeo so yeah big difference yeah
so but I learned how to be resilient and
how to fit in and all that good stuff
went to Notre Dame for college went to
be an architect for most listeners who
have no idea who mr. Brady is I wanted
to be mr. Brady from the Brady Bunch and
I was a show about family you know
coming together he was an architect I
thought it was cool job but I lasted one
semester and that didn't really like it
turned out I'm not a subjective person I
need objective things so change the
electoral engineering that's what dad
wanted me to do I didn't love that
either and had a girlfriend and said
well why don't you do what you like to
do like well it's a novel concept so I
did that and I did biology and chemistry
he thought it want to be a doctor
graduated pre-med took the MCATs bad
decision if you're not gonna be a doctor
don't take the MCATs decide before but
didn't go to med school went to business
school instead and came out and took the
first job offered as an insurance if I
was a resume inflator I'd say it was an
M&A analyst not a resume inflator so I
was a business analyst but what did I do
I made spreadsheets because back then no
one knew how to do spreadsheets because
they had just started existing from
visicalc to Lotus 1-2-3 and my boss
didn't know how to do spreadsheets so he
said hey do spreadsheets or we bought
little insurance companies into the
bigger insurance company and fate would
have it I said my life is a series of
happy accidents the guy who's doing
investments retired
and my boss said hey you want to invest
it like great so we started managing a
fixed income portfolio and what was
interesting about that is we did a
little bit of both we ran some of the
bonds in-house so learned about how to
do analysis on fixed income but also we
allocated some out and we found went out
to search for manager so I had my first
exposure and searching for talent and
got lucky hired Dan fuss before he was
famous legendary bond manager had
another guy Mike brilli up in
Minneapolis that no one had ever heard
of that had this really cool way of
buying bonds that were prepackaged into
these deals but were backed by US
Treasuries so you got a big boost and
yield even though he had real good
security
so we did that and interestingly and
this kind of goes to my whole history of
how I got to Notre Dame is I got a
letter you know people like what the
hell is a letter a physical one a letter
like physical letter with a stamp on it
and it was from my alma mater from Notre
Dame and said we're looking for an
assistant investment officer I'm like I
don't know what that is but hey I want
to go back to my alma mater so great so
I applied and went down I interviewed
and came down to me and another guy to
work in the Investment Office at Notre
Dame which was just being started and
turns out the other guy who had equity
experience I only had Bond experience
and Scott Malpass it was the CIO at the
time said I'm gonna go with the equity
guy I like disappointed but I don't
really think too much of it and I had my
first experience with everything happens
for a reason
there was a reason that happened and the
big reason was for those next two years
Scott really wasn't ready to let people
do investment stuff he just want someone
to build the spreadsheets in the back
office the infrastructure which I would
have hated not being a detail guy and
the new guy the guy took the job hated
it and two years later I gone to work
for an equity manager was down at Notre
Dame talking to Scott pitching him our
product and he said hey you still
interested and I said yeah I turned my
page paper around and said yeah write me
an offer I'll sign it today he
unfortunately didn't do that he actually
made me interview again and made me take
a test to make sure I could actually do
spreadsheets and I was a little
concerned because we were a year apart
at Notre Dame we live in the same dorm
say major pre-med two guys end up in
investing really we'll come back to that
topic which is a really important topic
why I think science training is the best
training for investing and I was nervous
about working for someone who's only a
year ahead of me and and somebody and he
had this great line he said don't worry
it's gonna be Batman and Batman I was
like alright that works for me and it
was great so I went spent five years at
Notre Dame and what was great about it
is you know I'd gone to work for two
professors at Northwestern we ran a
value investing style and we had a
billion dollars
back when a billion dollars was a lot of
money and these were like the first
professors that spun out of the
university to manage money and one of
the cool things about it it'll come back
to when we start talking about
technology is they were using technology
in a way that no one had before in
investing in that they were running
screens of stocks using the VAX computer
the big giant mainframe computer at
Northwestern so their professors during
the day they ran these screens at night
and they had this business on the side
that made them way more money the one
he's got from the professor from being
professors and they built this great
business and I probably would have
stayed there forever you know we had a
nice little business the top guys kept
all the money was young guys would have
eventually got something but I wanted to
go back to the alma mater and there's
this the story I tell that it's true
that Lou Holtz was the coach at
Minnesota at the time football coach and
he had a lifetime contract unless Notre
Dame called Notre Dame called he went
back to or he went to Notre Dame and had
a great career there 11 years and I had
the same thing I probably would have
stayed at discipline Investment Advisers
but I wanted to go back to Notre Dame
and and the cool thing again things
happen for a reason is I thought
investing was all about stocks and bonds
it was just about analysis and picking
stocks and bonds and when I got to Notre
Dame realized geez that has hardly
anything to do with it
investing is all about the big picture
about asset classes and about getting
out in front of big demographic and
secular trends and that's what we did
and and we did a bunch of things at
Notre Dame that to this day I tell
stories about that you know we're really
amazing I mean we started looking at
international private investing long
before other schools and and we followed
Stanford into some venture capital deals
that were extraordinary one being Google
you know we literally gave this company
that no one had heard of at the time
called Sequoia now everybody knows
Sequoia and Michael Moritz had never
done a deal at the time he was a brand
new guy at Sequoia and we gave him five
million dollars they took 10% of that
put in his little company called Google
and at the time people were like
Google it's a stupid name and why do we
need Google there's 20 search engines
we got Alta Vista we got web crawler my
personal favorite why do we need Google
well they had better technology that
nobody knew at the time well the guys at
Google knew but they did course and you
know the rest of the story is that 500k
turned into 200 million right there
should be a quad at Notre Dame called
the Google quad and so we did a lot of
good stuff and I learned a lot of great
things but you know spent five years
there loved it and then started to get
the calls and Jack Meyer had been a
mentor he was at Harvard I'd kind of run
into him through some conference stuff
and he decided to take me under his wing
and when the recruiters would call him
say hey who should be a CIO and say hey
call that usko guy and it was great and
I appreciated it and Chicago called
my other alma mater my business school
alma mater and interviewed there and
looked at that but then North Carolina
called and I said to my wife there's a
job in North Carolina should take it
don't you want to know what it is is no
I just want to live in North Carolina
and she was right and so we moved down
there sight unseen and the real thing
about North Carolina was it was broken
right if I'd gone to University of cago
I was good school had a good board had a
good portfolio good performance the
great thing about going to North
Carolina
it was totally broken 84th percentile in
performance they had like 11 managers
they had no diversification it was
managed by a board of eleven guys know
all guys okay and nine of them from the
same fraternity now this is what 97 97
98 right you go and take over the
endowment at a university North Carolina
yes and this board go ahead and explain
more about it so we all know that
diversity of thought is a good thing and
and new idea is a good thing but they
had nine guys from the same fraternity
all roughly the same age you know no
diversity on the board at all and they
would get together three or four times a
year for a football game or basketball
game and they were tried time the market
great strategy right yeah great and the
technical
term is they stunk yeah in fact they
stunk so badly that the guy right across
the street behind us
Julie Robertson had stepped off the
board and said guys you are terrible at
this so just give me five percent of the
endowment and I'll manage it and do do
great things he actually turned that
five into seventeen more on that later
but they really needed help and so the
Chancellor at the time Michael Hooker
one of those visionary guys I've ever
met said come to North Carolina help us
build this and he's the basketball
analogy since it's you know the mecca of
college basketball I got there the first
year and everything reversed tomahawk
slams everything we did look like a
genius now not because we were doing
anything smart but just because things
were really broken second year layups
third year free throws fourth year had
to take a jump shot it wasn't till the
fifth year we had to take a
three-pointer so we went from basically
me to a team of eight investment
professionals over the course of seven
years built out the back office we
actually spun ourselves out of the
university into a private management
company and did same fun things for
those they don't understand explain the
difference between having the endowment
inside of the school versus the
management company outside it because a
lot of schools could have kind of
pivoted to that model and just what the
difference is yeah it's it's an
important difference what a funny thing
so I get down in North Carolina and you
know we start to do things like
introduce an investment policy I mean
you're laughing eight they didn't have
an investment policy statement I'm
laughing because I know this story and
it's fantastic ok so crazy thing is so I
come in and I will admit I was a little
raw I was young it was 34 years old and
I didn't really understand politics and
so the first thing I did is I did my
first hundred days report you know like
the president does and I said here are
40 you know recommendations now what I
should have said was 40 observations
because recommendation implies that they
were doing something wrong so they took
it negatively so I got a little chest
for that but second thing I did is I
introduced this idea of an investment
policy you know again not a novel
concept and everyone had one and so I
started January 1998 all through 99 you
know things were going well we were
super long super strong super
concentrated in small caps and
international and crushed it and what
people forget is back in the fourth
quarter of 99 the Fed actually put half
a trillion back 1 half a trillion was a
lot of money into the economy to try to
ward off y2k everybody was afraid that
literally the world was going to shut
down on December 31st 1999 and so we did
really really well and we got really
overweight domestic equity international
equity small caps and so I go into the
board in February of 2000 and we had
this board meeting and a lot of things
were happening one stocks were super
overvalued and the forward projected
returns looked really unattractive and I
I showed this chart from GMO grantham a
event on Allu and it showed that the
expected return for US stocks for the
next decade was minus 1.9 and my board
chair said mark that's impossible that
could never happen and in fact you're
not allowed to use the letters GM Oro in
a sentence
ever again because this guy's always
wrong and he's going to be wrong and I
say fine fine but our policy says that
we're super overweight investment us
stocks we need to trim back to the
policy guidelines but basically we were
talking about is there's an investment
policy that had certain targets of asset
allocation and you had made investments
they'd grown so large that they'd gone
outside of those boundaries yeah if you
follow the policy you know you're very
balanced but if if you are going to meet
up with your buddies and make stock
picks then keep doing what you're what's
working and the thing is no one likes to
rebalance yep everybody likes to think
trees are going to grow the sky and
what's going to work yesterday is going
to work tomorrow and we actually know in
hindsight that's not
works course and you should definitely
rebound so I I go into this board
meeting say hey it's time to rebounce
that are you kidding these are our best
managers why would we take money away
from them said because that's the policy
that's the discipline and they're like
you know what we don't like this word
policy you you introduced this idea of
policy we're the board so I want you to
change that word to from policy to
guideline so I had to literally go to
the lawyers and change it to investment
guidelines so another meeting in May and
now I said you can't do anything so in
May the market started to roll over in
March starting to go down a little bit
the tech wreck was just starting and
they're like alright fine you can go to
the top end of the new guidelines but no
more because these are our best managers
no way we can take any money away from
them and come back in September and
they're like get this [ __ ] out of here
yep and oh yeah change that word back to
policy like okay good so now they got it
and and we went on to do a lot more
active rebalancing and a lot more
discipline and in fact over the next
couple quarters we rebalance the
portfolio from long and strong - very
hedged because by the middle of 2002 the
first part of 2001 we're starting to
come up on a recession people didn't
really see it coming actually kind of
like now and we said that it was time
for getting hedged and so I go to the
board meeting I said we want it we want
to add hedge funds like well that that's
gonna be a problem I said well why is
that he said well we banned hedge funds
what do you mean you banned hedge funds
well back in 1996 julian robertson and
get had taken the assets from the
portfolio and he had grown them to a
really big waiting but he had a bad year
in 1996 he was down 9% the market was up
a few percent and Businessweek wrote
this article called the fall of the
wizard and it basically said the julian
was washed up he never be good again he
was up a hundred percent the next 12
months but you know who's counting and
so I said well that seems like a really
bad plan but okay fine no hedge funds so
we'll have no hedge funds will
opportunistic equity long-short equity
enhanced fixed income and absolute
return and the Chancellor looks at me
says that's just nomenclature right I
said yeah
this is good as long as we're clear and
so we did go to 66 zero percent in those
four strategies over the next 12 months
and from 2000 to 2002 you know markets
fell almost 60 percent average endowment
lost 25 percent their money and we were
flat now say I'm never gonna you know
break my arm pat myself on the back for
not making money but flat was good when
the rest of the world was down a lot and
it taught me the value of discipline
following your policy the value of
hedging the value of not really focusing
on past performance but focusing on
what's going to happen in the future and
really focusing on talent because at the
end of the day what we were doing is we
were concentrating the portfolio in the
most talented people and it worked out
really well and because of that in 2002
I got approached by a couple wealthy
families that hadn't done as well during
the the downdraft and and they said hey
come be our CIO I said well that's
interesting but I'm not sure I want to
work for just one family but hey I could
create a business that could manage
money for lots of families and so we set
out to do that and we had this idea to
create this this company came up with
lots of names and all good names were
taken all the birds of prey all the big
cats everything was taken so Laura
finally said hey if you name it after a
physical place then you can use it all
right well I live on Morgan Creek so
what about Morgan great and you know my
house was back up to Morgan Creek and
Morgan Creek runs through the middle
Chapel Hill it's actually the Creek that
James Taylor grew up on with his family
when his dad was the Dean of the medical
school and the song copper line is all
about Morgan Creek so if you look at our
card in our logo it has a little copper
line through it well nod to JT and so we
we decide to leave or I decide to leave
so I went with these two families who
set up Morgan Creek and the idea was to
bring the endowment model of invest
two families high-net-worth individuals
smaller institutions that didn't have
staff and resources explain what the
endowment model is for they don't know
yep so the endowment model of investing
is really pretty simple it's it's a
model that that says if you think about
investing there's only four ways you can
make money right they all require you to
take risk so you can take credit risk
you can buy a bond and a bond you know
if they don't pay you back you can sue
them it's a contractual claim so you
don't make a lot of money for bonds
above risk-free they you can take equity
risk so stocks and hedge funds
the idea is you you get paid more for
that because the contingent claim you
only get paid if the bondholders get
paid first and then you can take a
liquidity risk so private equity private
real estate private energy private debt
and you get paid more for illiquidity
because you're willing to lock your
money up for some period of time and
then there's structure which is just
fancy term for leverage or or derivative
structure and what the endowments
figured out was bonds really aren't
gonna work for me because I need to make
five percent real meaning five percent
above inflation to pay my spending so I
need to take more risk to achieve that
if I'm only make two percent real and
bonds that's not going to work so I'm
gonna have less allocation of bonds I'm
gonna have more allocation to equities
long-term equities but then within
equities there's all kinds of equity
right there's private equity there's
real estate equity there's commodity
equity there's stock equity so I'm gonna
take advantage of this illiquidity
premium and that means I might have a
high weight in private investments and
then I'm also gonna have a value bias
and I'm gonna have disciplined I'm gonna
follow this policy so all of these
things are what the Yale model and the
endowment model were all about and if
you look over the last 20 years at that
time the endowments and foundations that
outperformed everybody by a wide margin
we're talking three four hundred basis
points per year compounded for 20 years
which is a lot of return and it was
really from the simple having a policy
having discipline focusing on talent
focusing on illiquidity premium and and
then the last thing and we probably
talked about this more later is is this
idea that innovation
as an asset class is really important
and that always backing innovation back
like when we've backed Google at Notre
Dame or other companies that did
interesting things one of my favorite
stories about that is this great story
about a company called Siena and back
during the recession you know one this
guy gets laid off from Bell Labs and he
says hey can I take my project with me
and the people like I don't know what
you're working on you know okay fine
take it
knock yourself out and yeah actually how
about and so he takes it and no one
would back him and he he had this idea
he was gonna shine light through a prism
and that that would break the light into
multiple colors and each color of light
should in theory be able to transmit the
same amount of data as white light so
fiber optic cable could be expanded
without having to add more cables and no
one believed him except this retired
school teacher who gave him three
hundred thousand dollars which probably
her life savings now the cool thing is
it turned into three hundred million
dollars for her so that's cool but he
created this company which went on to
change the way information flowed around
the world because you could now increase
the capacity of fiber optics but that
was innovation right that was thinking
differently or thinking not even
thinking like out of the box but
thinking like there is no box coming up
with a whole different way of attacking
a problem so this endowment model and
this way of thinking be a value investor
really resonated with a lot of families
we grew the business the term outsource
cio really didn't exist in fact I we
might have even coined it in our
original presentation OCIO but we did
something that in hindsight was dumb we
picked a good business but a bad
business model all right so first let's
talk about what the business itself so
the OCIO model explain the difference
between when you're an endowment cio you
basically manage the capital and now it
has itself when you got approached by
these families the initial pitches basic
come work for us right come around our
investment our so you are working for a
single pool of capital the OCIO model is
doing variation of that yeah but now
you're doing it for multiple pools of
capital simultaneously yep right and and
before I said I'll actually answer the
original question you asked me which I
do all the time you asked a question and
I'll just go down some rabbit hole but
you asked the question about why was it
important that we spun out of the
University and this is this an important
question in the sense that universities
for years were run by teams of people
internally most of them were kind of
pretend CIOs they were like the
accounting office that started to do it
or back at Notre Dame before Scott and I
got there he was literally a priest who
once a year he would go to New York and
whoever bought him the nicest dinner he
would allocate them some money and and
that's how he did it he was a nice guy
and but he wasn't an investment
professional and the problem is a snake
expert yeah exactly
it's steak expert and at a play hey he
was good at Broadway and I said really
nice guy the funny thing is he actually
got the job this greatest title ever as
procreator General at the Vatican which
is like the top finance guy at the
Vatican interesting name but what's
interesting about it is if you think
about the pay scale at a public
university or any university it's pretty
low and so you're not gonna attract the
best talent and so you're doing the best
with what you can and so there are two
ways you can can fix it one is you can
allow people to consult like a med
school prof that you know sees patients
on Fridays or dental school prophet
drills teeth on Wednesdays so one things
they did for me is they said okay you
can consult right you can we'll pay you
you know your salary but then you can
consult the wealthy families and I did
that and it's supplemented my income
which was nice but the second thing is I
when i went to hire my first guy it's
amazing so i found this this guy and he
was a moorhead scholar which is the top
scholarship at unc but i talked more
about that kind of stuff later but he
was amazing right he was being recruited
by goldman sachs you know he had been
voted greek Man of the Year I mean
really impressive guy top of his class
and I want to hire him and he was
willing to stay and work for us for 35 K
instead of 50 when you compare this back
in 1998
and yeah because his girlfriend was here
behind is still it at school and I go to
the University and say okay I want to
hire this guy said well you don't have
that position I said what do you mean I
said we I just want an analyst they said
well you know what do you mean I said
well an analyst investment analyst so
well you don't have that position so
well okay but the state you know has an
investment management firm and they've
got that position and I could just
borrow their position description from
the state fuss because you do everything
through the state because we're State
University they said well they manage
money what the heck is our billion
dollars like well but you don't
physically imagine I'm like oh we
allocate to other people and they manage
but we're still managing money make a
long story short they wouldn't have said
they said you could pay him twenty two
thousand dollars I said but I won't get
him for twenty three thousand dollars I
need 35 this is sorry so the the
attorney you know thing I would helped
me with the guidelines thing said hey
you know there's this thing if you hire
someone as a consultant then you can pay
them whatever so we literally had to
sell him to a temp services agency and
then rent him back and we paid thirty
five plus fifteen percent so we ended up
paying fifteen percent that we shouldn't
have but we were able to hire and so
getting talent is really important and
what Yale and Harvard and and Harvard's
the epitome of it is they spun the whole
organization into a management company
and it allowed them to attract the best
talent so we followed suit and Duke had
done it and if Duke does then Carolina's
got to do it and so we spun into a
management company and it allowed us to
hire better talent so the same thing in
terms of forming Morgan Creek is is we
knew that we wanted to have this
investment company structure that would
be then a resource to multiple families
or institutions and so like when I said
Michael hooker who is the Chancellor at
UNC was a visionary the reason he got me
to come to North Carolina was he said
hey I have this idea we could we could
manage money for UNC Chapel Hill then we
could manage money for all the other
schools in the UNC system then we could
manage money for other public
universities around the country then we
could manage money for
you know the alumni we could create
mutual funds and then we could take it
public I mean that is a guy when I hitch
my cart to or horse cart to his horse
unfortunately he passed away two years
after I got there and expectedly from
cancer and the board never really bought
into his vision they're like well we
don't want to share like it's not
sharing if we manage those people's
money we charge a fee then we have more
resources then we can hire better talent
then you get better performance it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy but they didn't
see it that way
so I moved into this model where I could
say alright we're gonna build a resource
a management company and I brought most
of my team from Carolina hired a couple
of the guys that had my eye on and I
said alright we're gonna build a shared
resource an outsourced resource so you
could hire us to be your team and for
the price of maybe one person you could
get a whole organization and a better
team and it was a way of building access
to talent in a way that they really
hadn't been done before so it was great
and the mistake we made though in the
business model was the model we chose
OCIO outsource CIO doesn't scale it's a
great business bad business model
because if you say I'm an outsourced
investment office and you're gonna have
account reps like I have ten people I
serve and you have ten people you serve
the problem was every time I'd say okay
Mike's gonna be your person they say no
it says OCIO you're the CIO I need to
see you
well I can only see like 15 people so we
capped our growth whereas other firms
like Cambridge associates and Northern
Trust figure it out if we have more
equal based people you know senior
investment people but not the CIO
then we can have lots of people have ten
people we can scale to hundreds or even
thousands because it comes out of what
people think they're buying right they
are they buying an office or they buying
the CIO are they buying some of the
resource and it's almost like you did
such a good job selling them on this
you're buying the outsourced CIO that
they sent home where is he yeah where's
the guy
show up it was a great run and we really
do it we still have you know some of
that that business today 15 years later
hard to believe it's been 15 years but
more just turned 50 just turned 15 we
just celebrated our 15th anniversary she
was pretty cool
absolutely alright so you do the OCIO
stuff obviously you start to realize hey
this is great
but I want you tell story about how you
get from the OCIO model to more of kind
of a dedicated fund model yep and some
of the challenges of tracking down
wealthy people it's great so you know we
we start with these these handful of
families and they grew that to a number
of families but we launched in July of
2004 and cetera October November
that's when Thanksgiving is November of
2004 literally we're trying to get a
deal done for a million dollar
investment in an energy fund and we had
to track down the patriarch of this one
family on a yacht in the Mediterranean
trying to use faxes and ship-to-shore
radio and realize this is stupid right
so we need to have a vehicle where we
have discretion because one of the
challenges of investing with talent you
know the best hedge fund manager is the
best venture capital managers when they
give you access you have to take it you
don't have time to go you know touch
everybody and ask you know do you want
this or not want this because you have
to then educate this is really is the
best person you know and Blue Ridge
opens up they got a small window you
need to grab that that capacity and so
we said alright here's a renewed we're
gonna create these commingled vehicles
and so for hedge funds for private
investments for venture capital real
estate we're gonna create these
commingled pools and all the families
are gonna participate in those if you
still want to have custom hedge funds or
custom individual funds fine but the
bulk of the exposures got to be in these
commingled vehicles we set up you know
Morgan Creek partners to do private
investments we set up the opportunity
fun to do hedge funds we set an absolute
return fund and we did these commingled
vehicles or fund of funds I had to call
manager of managers because
we're actually managing the portfolios
and we had a unique model and that 75%
of the money was with external managers
25% was with Co investments and we would
Co invest in deals or in individual
ideas side by side with the managers and
that turned out to work really really
well and so over time some of our
biggest investors said hey we love what
you do in fund of funds but what we
really love is this idea of co investing
and so we created Co investment vehicles
in fact you know you and I met through
through a co investment that will
probably talk about later and what was
interesting is at first people were
resistant right because they felt that
they were gonna lose control you know
they wanted to make individual decisions
and what we got them to realize is it
wasn't the individual decision of
whether you're in manager a B or C it
was are you moving into energy at the
right time are you moving out of stocks
at the right time are you moving into
venture capital at the right time are
you going into tech or healthcare and so
once they got comfortable with that and
once they had a relationship that they
felt comfortable with we moved them
towards that business but it was really
this idea of of accessing talent and I
say all tied that
yeah I'd literally for most of my career
you know 30 plus years I had the best
job in the world
I get paid to go around the world and
talk to the smartest people in the world
about investing how awesome is that I
mean literally I've talked to Nobel
laureates I've talked to you know some
of the greatest investors of all time
I've been mentored by some of the
greatest investors of all time like
Julian across the street you know what a
blessing to spend you know a decade or
more with that guy that I could go see
him anytime I wanted he would give me
ideas he would give me you know
philosophy and he'd give me instruction
you tell me what I was wrong
but you learned so much by going out and
interacting with really talented people
and it's also pattern recognition
because if you don't see everybody in
the business then you don't know what's
good and what's bad in fact a good story
about that when you might not have even
heard I don't know I've heard most of my
stories at this
this one might be unique so the first
family that hired us one of the
challenges they had is is they had a
really bad experience in private
investments well the reason is very
simply is back in 2000 right before they
hired us they had met with 34 private
equity groups and they had hired 17 of
them now they committed three deadly
sins in investing and I'll ask you which
one was the worst so was the worst that
they only met with 34 okay because they
were actually 450 in the market that
year but they met the thirty-fourth at
Credit Suisse and Merrill Lynch brought
to them because those are their you know
marketing people or was this the worst
sin that they had hired more than 50%
where he should really only hire kind of
1 to 3 percent of the people you see or
was the fact that the 34 they saw were
all tech because tech had done great 96
97 98 99 so I'm gonna go with option 3
that's the big mistake
yeah is big mistake very big mistake and
and and you know I wouldn't tell the
story if it didn't have the ending I
want which is yeah it didn't work out
and it made them realize that one they
needed someone to help them understand
that you shouldn't chase the hot dot you
shouldn't just go with what's been good
you've got to actually look I say all
the time the best performance comes from
people have a great long term track
record who've just get and they're just
gotten their butt kicked and they just
had a really tough period that's when
you want to buy them and what you're
talking about there's two pieces here so
one is if you were to ask many great
venture capitalists etc you know would
you rather bet on the team on a specific
company product or the market don't like
look a great team is actually really
advantageous and kind of talent you're
talking about but if you invest in the
right market you can actually invest
with a bad team and the tailwind will
take care of a lot of the fault so I
don't kind of cover that up if you
invest with a great team and a horrible
market good luck all right even the best
teams in the world just if there's not
customers if there's not whatever and so
it's it's similar to the asset
allocation of are you in the right
assets yes you start to go do the work
on the man
and right strategies etc but a good
portion of it is just simply in the
right assets or indirect investing in
private just actually in the right
market just being in the right place
there our time is is everything in
investing and and I do think that that
founders and teams can make a big
difference and the talent ultimately
wins and well I'm sure we'll talk more
about that but to your point you know
when I first got to UNC in 98 literally
my first board meeting and I've been
there seven days I go to a board meeting
and at the time there was this famous
cover of The Economist magazine and it
basically said the world of washing oil
and it was a picture of these oil guys
on the front trying to stop a geyser
gusher from from flowing they're covered
in oil and and in the article it said
that oil oil was about 11 bucks at the
time it said oil was going to $5 and it
actually had a line saying someday oil
might be free okay so I go in and again
we just had our new policy implemented
and you know I'm saying okay with our
new policy put a 5% target to energy and
natural resources we have zero and I
want to give 1% to this firm called
natural gas partners even though they
really did more oil and gas there was
three guys trained by Richard rainwater
one of the famous investors of all time
and a Texas and I I make the pitch and
and the board chair says mark that's the
dumbest idea I've ever heard but if you
really want to do it okay I'm Mike great
awesome okay and rest the meeting goes
on it calls me in the chancellor's
office after the meeting and he says
mark when I say that's the dumbest idea
I've ever heard that's what I meant the
rest of the stuff was just to be nice in
front of all the people and the
Chancellor says well max right I mean if
we're not gonna take his ideas we should
just fire them right now but if we're
good
take his ideas but I think we should try
at least and we just brought them down
here you know makes you try a couple
ideas then if they don't work out we can
fire him like guys I'm sitting right
here
on day seven fire
is not not interesting to me what
stitching is they did let us put 5% in
energy and that 5% energy generated 25%
of UNC's returns the next decade good
not because I'm a genius but because
we're in the right place right time we
partnered with great people
Marit Marit Energy Partners and natural
gas partners and a few others but to
your point it was really about being in
the right asset and I also think that
was the right asset class right market
type stuff but one of my favorite
sayings that you have is about timing
right and this idea of people buying and
selling things maybe when they shouldn't
so maybe go over a little bit of a
framework it's everything to to what we
talked about up to this point on on you
know the board right is there's this
great piece by barton biggs he wrote two
pages he was a famous strategist for
morgan stanley and he wrote this thing
called group stink and it's the best two
pages i think i've ever read about the
psychology of investing in and why
there's there's truth in this idea that
an investment committee should be made
up of an odd number of members and three
is too many so groups don't make good
decisions groups particularly boards
make really bad decisions and why is
that it's not because they're not smart
people they're incredibly smart people
that's why they get it to be on the
board but once you get on the board
what's the most important thing stay on
the board and so what you do is you you
make decisions that are are homogeneous
and that aren't controversial and so i
used to keep track and and when we would
recommend stuff to the board about 95
percent of time they would approve it
and the five percent that they didn't
approve were by far our best ideas and
that's not a criticism of them are
saying we're of geniuses and they're
idiots no no just the opposite it's we
were kind of being idiots at the time
because we were really pushing the
envelope and the things that sound the
craziest at the time the things you get
the most pushback are usually the best
ideas because they're really pushing the
boundary
the edge of the opportunity and so when
my board sure says mark that's the
dumbest idea I've ever heard
well that's the trigger ding-ding-ding
anything that they do ring a bell when
it's time to go because when everybody's
telling you that something is terrible
that's one thing I love about Twitter
right is I can put an idea out there and
I get instantaneous vitriol or hatred
I'm like oh that's a good idea if
everybody said Oh mark that's the great
thing ever cheese okay that's already in
the market and so well in a lot of its
coming from just it's probably something
that's either controversial or pushing
the edge is something that not a lot of
other people are thinking about or doing
and so if you're able to do something
that other people aren't doing and it's
right that's where a lot of the returns
end up being anyways oh come on it's my
pin tweet right yeah the greatest wealth
is created by investing in something
that you believe in before people even
understand it and that has been true
forever right from the early days of
when you know the idea of carried
interest was started you know Queen
Isabella sends Christopher Columbus off
with these ships and and she says I want
I want carried interest well let's think
about that for say twenty percent of
profits care the stuff they carried back
in the ships she got twenty percent of
so she was a venture capitalist and no
one thinks about her as a venture
capitalist and you know the actually
even goes back further than Queen
Isabella in that if you go to Greece
where I know you were last summer and
you go down the peninsula there's a very
thin point where I can forget which the
Corinthians built a track seven miles
long the the narrowest point and if you
went down around the panoply that can
never have pronounced it but when you
were sailing back then back in the early
days it was really treacherous and so
literally people would pull into port
and they'd load up the boat on this
track and the slaves would push it
across the Isthmus and get to their side
you'd be safe well there is a carried
interest I mean they took a percentage
of what you had the bow
probably made it lighter too and so that
idea of sharing the wealth came from an
idea that no one had really thought
about or again thinking outside the box
but in terms of investing and timing
it's it's definitely clear that the best
investment ideas are the ones that are
the least popular well I think the ones
say that you say all the time that it
cracks me up because it's so true is
about people basically buying the things
that they should have bought yeah and
then selling the things that they need
it's so easy to do what everyone else is
doing and when is it easy to do what
everyone else is doing well after
something's gone up so human beings do
two things really really well one to
your point is they buy what they wish
they would have bought and we're
spectacular at it and it's true of
everything is true of fads right you
know people buy the hot piece of
clothing right at the end of its life
not the beginning when people would say
it looks stupid and then it doesn't have
a good useful life or they buy an
investment after it's already gone up
you know back in 2000 we set the
all-time record for money flowing into
tech stocks in three months January
February and March of 2000 not in 1980
right when the cover of Businessweek
said the death of equities and stocks
were super cheap and you could have
bought all the equities in the United
States twice with all the gold in the
world
no nobody bought stocks then they waited
twenty plus years until they had gone up
and they had gone up a lot and people
piled in and bought Sisco at crazy
prices and then watched it fall 90 plus
percent and so human beings are
spectacular buying what they wish they
would've bought but the second thing
they do which is equally bad is they
sell what they're about to need and so
you know you look at it let's take
energy right now energy stocks are on
their pass everything is is everyone
hates energy and the electric cars are
gonna be you know the next great in
twenty years it's gonna take a long time
to get really
in an internal combustion engine even if
we should get rid of it faster it's
gonna take a long time but soil is gonna
be with us for a long time and there are
a lot of oil companies that have just
gotten obliterated and everybody's
flowing into Fang and I say you know
right now you should be selling Fang
Facebook Amazon Netflix Google you
should be buying Fang Diamondback energy
because nobody wants to own it
same thing with hedge funds you know
hedge funds have underperformed during
the QE era they've had a horrible
performance because it's tough to short
stocks because the idea of shorting is
you're supposed to sell short companies
that are bad and usually companies are
bad go out of business but if you
artificially suppress interest rates and
make money free and allow companies that
have no business borrowing money to
continue to borrow money to stay alive
then shorting stocks is really hard
and so hedge funds have struggled but
right now we're at the precipice of a
really tough period in markets where
you're gonna wish you were hedged and
it's just like back in 99 2000 2001 when
I was at UNC and telling them they need
to get hedged like no I want to give
money to Tom MARSOC oh because he's been
up well right and I think part of it is
it goes back to you know when you're
sitting there you're saying look
equities over the next 10 years you know
negative 1.9 percent and they're saying
that's impossible right it is humans are
very revisionist in history right in
terms of when they look back it's of
course this is going to continue right
and they will even say things like well
it won't continue forever but it's gonna
continue for the next five years the
next 10 years right it's this that the
market shift or I think you know Ray
Dalio recent doesn't about paradigm
shifts we're you know timing those are
really difficult but actually kind of
looking around the room is a great
signal as to when maybe I should be
thinking differently than everyone else
in this room because they are so excited
that if everyone is excited it may pay
to actually not be as excited as they
are yeah yeah it's really interesting
too because you hit on a really
important point and it's subtle that
people don't think about is
doing the opposite of everybody else all
the time is a really bad strategy right
and Soros has a great quote about this
is that the trend actually is your
friend oh the only time it's not is that
inflection points and one of the things
that's interesting is you don't want to
just resist the the markets movements or
the or the trend or you know whether
it's a secular move or a cyclical move
just to be contrarian so being a
contrarian for a contrarian sake is is a
dangerous strategy but what's really
important is is the subtle point you
said is when you're looking around the
room and suddenly everybody is leaning
one way or everybody is on one side of
the boat that's when it starts to pay to
start walking towards the other side not
necessarily right away but pretty
quickly and making those decisions at
inflection points and people so how do
you know when there's reflection point
well inflection points are really cool
in the sense that they advertise
themselves it's it's like a phase shift
back to you know chemistry it's like a
phase shift between water and ice or you
know water and steam is what happens is
right before that shift the atoms start
to vibrate very rapidly and the same
thing happens in markets markets have
low volatility during a trend and then
what happens is they're starting to have
really high volatility so if you look at
you know just take last week in the
equity markets we are up 3% up down 1%
up 2% down 2% and that volatility tends
to spike right as things are about to
shift or change for those that are only
used to the crypto markets those are big
movements in the equity world yeah exact
an exact a huge steel in the equity
markets so another piece of this I guess
is you said it you don't necessarily
need to shift immediately right so when
you kind of get that the gyration of the
markets of the volatility the other
thing that I see a lot of people
especially right now given that there's
some people yelling and screaming saying
hey there's some gyration going on is
you don't have to go from long to
immediately a hundred percent short oh
right right there's an element of
making a move to cash for example yeah
he's actually a decision it is an
investment yeah and what you're doing is
you're basically taking risk off and you
are not necessarily betting on the
inflection point but what you're doing
is you're hedging yourself to some
degree and when something does happen
right let's say the markets do roll over
the people who have done that have
actually positioned themselves the best
because they're the ones who have all
the liquidity and can buy when everyone
else is selling again such an important
point and if you think about the
greatest investors of all time
they are very judicious in their use of
cash and they don't view cash as not an
investment you know the industry is gone
to this point about you know unless
you're fully invested you're not a real
investor well know that that's silly
cash is an investment it's a choice to
to your point and and being short is a
really tough business
you know shorting companies John Griffin
who ran ran the famous hedge fund Blue
Ridge described it best it's like
playing chess you know if you try to
short during the opening you know three
phases of a chess game the opening the
middle game at the end game if you try
too short in the opening there's just a
waste of time because you have no idea
you and I start a chess game no you have
no idea who's the better player at the
beginning it's just a waste of time in
the middle game where the strategy is
coming and the big moves are being made
that's when it can just be lethal
because it can go against you really
badly
it's only in the endgame right where you
know who's gonna win when you want a
short and so you do get you get signals
in in equities as to when that that
endgame is occurring and I'm sure we'll
talk at some point about Tesla and all
and all that but I think about this all
the time in that if you if you think
about cash I even have a hashtag for
cash is king
that I cash tags by the way cash is king
in that the reason it's king is it has
very high option value and you know
somebody I can remember who was it would
be better if I could remember give him
credit but they call it
market valium because it takes the
stress out you know if you're fully
invested or fully short you have stress
right if it goes against you your you
might make bad decisions because you
know you're trying to try to stop the
bad things from happening to your
portfolio
whereas in cash you just get the ability
to sit back and watch and observe and
then to your point when you have
liquidity when no one else does
you win I mean think back is the co shot
really is it's the kill shot right in
markets where if nobody else has
liquidity and there's a liquidity crunch
and you're the one sitting there with
liquidity you dictate what you do
dictate you get to buy all the best
assets because no one else can buy them
and you can they're at the perfect price
a huge margin of safety you get all the
upside and and you also get flexibility
in how you structure you know it's kind
of like you know after the the global
financial crisis you know who was there
with lots of cash and he didn't even buy
stock he bought convertible bonds you
know Warren Buffett because he got the
first call and why'd he get the first
call well who had enough cash to bail
out Bank of America or Goldman Sachs or
you know any numerous other deals that
he did and it's the money the people who
have bailed out the government or bailed
out banks they always are the wealthiest
with lots of liquidity oh come on I mean
one of my favorite stores right is you
go back to you know the last time the
banks were threatened okay 1907 you had
this thing called the Knickerbocker
panic and what was the Knickerbocker
panic
well the trust companies were trying to
create alternatives to banks and there's
this guy JP Morgan you might have heard
of him he didn't like that so much
because he was the banks and he
basically started a rumor that some of
these trust companies were were
insolvent and that you better get your
money out fast so he literally triggered
a bank run the Knickerbocker panic of
1907 and these trust companies all
started to falter and magically he and
rockefeller one of his good friends were
able to pick them up at a very bargain
basement price and get rid of the
competition and you know then they went
even further and turns out John D
Rockefellers dad our father-in-law was a
Bri Aldrich and they came up with this
plan to create the Federal Reserve Bank
and it took him four years from 1909 to
1913 to actually get it passed they call
it the Jekyll or the monster of Jekyll
Island for a reason well worse things
that ever happened but unless your
banker because it was created basically
keep the bankers rich and it's done a
really good job at that and but when you
have liquidity right when you can write
a twenty five million dollar check when
that's a lot of money back then to save
the banking system so to speak even
though you created its demise in the
first place but it's what is it theity
arsonist who sets the fire and then
shows up as a fireman and pass himself
on the back we have somebody who's doing
that in other places yeah but it's
really interesting over time when you
think about this idea of liquidity and
having liquidity at exactly the right
time is is how you make the biggest
returns and Stan Druckenmiller has a
line about this he says you know the way
you you make big returns is preservation
of capital and home runs well how do you
preserve capital well one you avoid
buying overvalued assets to you don't
reject the idea that cash is an asset
and can have huge protective value
because you can't be wrong right your
own cash you're not gonna lose money on
it and then third is this idea of home
runs is how do you get home runs well
when you get an edge yeah my big thing
in my Twitter feed is hashtag edge when
you get an edge whatever that edge is
you have to have the courage or the guts
to really bet big and you think about
when druk was with Soros and all the
things they did when they had an edge
whether it was with
or whether it was in a certain company
or certain asset class and they would
wait patiently with lots and lots of
cash they would preserve capital and
then they would pounce and the other
thing about this that's really
interesting and you know most people
don't don't understand this about
investing but preservation of capitals
are really important and and it's what
differentiates the real long-term
winners from the losers but the thing
that separates the really great
investors from from the just good
investors is the uncanny ability to
double up and to press the winners so I
want to make sure that we talk about
this because I talked about it before on
the on the podcast one time I asked you
I said what is the biggest difference
between the top five best investors in
the world and the top 1% so I wasn't
interested in you know what separates
the good from they're not good or even
the great from the good but the absolute
five best from there really really
really good right so basically what
separates that that you know five best
from their peers and you said to me well
it's that ability to double up up to you
to a specific orig I think your specific
statement was they cut their losers
faster than anyone yeah and they press
the winners harder then yeah okay yes
there are two parts to it thank you for
my yeah that's exactly right so yo Soros
has the line right I'm only rich because
I admit my mistakes faster than other
people
and what most people do is the exact
opposite and what you should do is we
water our weeds and we pull our flowers
as soon as we make a little bit of money
we pull the flower I'm up 10% I want no
no add more because it's going to
continue to go and what we do is when
we're wrong we try to justify all the
markets wrong and I'm right or I'm early
euphemism for wrong and I'm gonna be
right later and so the color cost
averaging down yeah and everybody says
I'm gonna a ver äj-- never ever ever
averaged down it's just it's a horrible
decision
and people say well mark you're a value
investor and you say all the time that
you should average down
well averaging down is different than
buying more of something as it becomes
cheaper the difference is when when
you're speculating on something when
you're buying something just on price
and it moves against you you're just
wrong right
when you buy something with a margin of
safety and it continues to deteriorate
because everybody else is puking it out
like the energy stocks today then you
you've done the analysis you have the
edge you have the the ability to to buy
more so some couldn't it pick and say
that's the same thing I'll grant that
actually but but what you're talking
about specifically is this difference
between price and value yes which I
think that is very maybe not very well
understood but but well discussed in
traditional markets in the crypto world
is almost a non-existing conversation
right and what you're specifically
talking about is if you're making
investment decisions based on price
alone then you very quickly know you're
right or you're wrong right it's very
easy to measure quantitative basis when
you are making a value based investment
so not necessarily related to the price
but you understand what an asset is
worth based on whatever that analysis
and the price is below that value yep
the price movement is almost less
important as is it still below the value
correct right the relation to the value
is much more important than is it up
five or ten percent today or down five
or ten percent today because you want to
continue to buy the asset that is
undervalued in price as long as it is
under valid notice it's exactly exactly
right and really well said we must have
been hanging out together but you know
it's interesting in a sense that cutting
losers is is critically important and
the first loss is the best loss and not
not trying to convince the world you're
right in the markets wrong but this this
real uncanny ability and to me what
separates the the truly top-five from
from everybody else is this uncanny
ability to
double up and you know I'd said I've had
the luxury of having julian robertson as
a mentor and and friend and he up seed
Morgan Creek when we got started and
Becks funny story is I got this email
when I announced my resignation and and
it said say it ain't so Julian you know
choose Joe Jackson and I joke I don't
get a lot of emails from billionaires in
fact at that time that was my first one
and I got a couple others since then but
that was the first one and hit the bid
and I came up to New York and walked in
the building across the street went up
the 48th floor and and I shook I thought
I was gonna get my Nike shoe deal and
because of what he talked about like
well Nike shoe deal is works like this
is the coach at the University doesn't
make a lot of money from the University
he gets the money from his Nike shoe
deal and television and radio and all
this stuff or an alumni slush fund and
so I figured that Julie was gonna say
hey Mark I know we can't pay enough but
you know we'll find a way to get you
some more money and instead I walk in he
comes out he puts his arm around me says
mark I'm surprised you lasted that long
I like you and I want to work together
like hit that bid and so he can under
the Nike deal better than I could do way
better and but but because I got close
to him I had the the luxury one of them
investing with all the great firms spun
out of there from Blue Ridge to Lone
Pine to maverick to you know just dozens
of firms and got to know those guys and
one of the cool things I did as I would
I would interview all these guys on on
Julian and I've these notebooks full of
a patient's primary book on what made
him great it was amazing you ever would
had a different perspective you know the
macro guys would talk about his macro
views or that the underlying guys would
would say you know one of favorite
things about Julian he said you know
never fudged to the numbers if you don't
know don't start talking because he'll
know and you know the other one was just
about competitiveness right if you're
not competitive you're out and done
better competitive in what right can be
tennis golf tiddlywinks
you know equestrian doesn't matter just
he
to be competitive and then the others
honesty and integrity that there's
there's nothing else without that and so
but the thing they all said you know
30-plus of these interviews that I've
done they all said he had this uncanny
ability to double up so when most people
are afraid because you know they've made
money and they don't lose it he's adding
to it and that ability to see the future
it's it's the Jeff Bezos to say I'm
gonna make this a world-changing
technology and people like know it's a
bookstore online who cares like no it's
it's bigger than that and you know it's
the ability to ride with it and here's a
Mexican thing about Amazon so Amazon
went public in 1998 so it's been public
for twenty years in every single year
including this year it's had a
double-digit draw down the average
drawdown is 31 percent so I said how
many people actually bought the IPO in
98 and still hold the stock today that
would be Jeff and his parents that's it
because everybody else got shaken out
cuz twice it was down more than 90% but
to have the ability to hold through that
volatility because you just have a a
belief and a passion in this being a
great business and a great business
model and a great investment is is
really a superpower it is an absolute
superpower and I've only had the
experience on a handful of occasions
over time stead of I've literally met
with thousands of managers I mean you
know did 400 meetings a year for most of
my career people always called [ __ ]
on that I'm like well like give me my
calendar and only a handful of times if
I walked away saying you know that
person has it and it is the ability to
to be a true believer to really hold
something dear than everybody else
questions and I remember having this
this conversation with a manager out in
California and we still invest with him
today
and he worked at this firm called
integral capital with this famous guy
Roger McNamee kind of Grateful Dead kind
of rocker and Glen worked with him and
and it was amazing and Google had just
gone public and was starting to fall and
a value manager friend of mine said uh
you know Google's not not worth 50 bucks
and it you know gone public at 50 gone
to 100 it was falling back and and I'm
sitting there saying you know I I really
don't know why you owned Google and and
you should you should really probably
sell according to my value manager
friend and Glen looks at me says mark
you're crazy you just don't you just
understand this has nothing to do with
value today it has to do with what this
technology is capable of and how it can
be monetized in all these ways and and I
listened to him and I just went wow okay
he's a true believer and clearly Google
it a thousand Glen was right and you
know Richard was wrong but that ability
to not just own it and be happy just
making some money but to keep buying
more of it and to really press those big
winners and you know that's where great
fortunes are created skirts girl want to
know who has the best URL crypto calm
that's right
crypto calm they're crypto platform with
one goal mother mass adoption that's why
we're all here we're trying to get
crypto in every wallet crypto calm is
helping people do that through buying
earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto calm
go help your boy out
tell them pump sent you download the app
or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an Xbox or a Playstation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right
you purchase it it shows up at your
doorstep you pull it out of the box you
plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi five
minutes or less you're mining Bitcoin
all you have to do
is controlled from the mobile app they
provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mind
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mine com
tell them pom sent you and thank me
later it always cracks me up the one
saying that I love which is you have to
be very careful with because if you're
wrong this works against you but the
idea that concentration builds wealth
and diversification preserves it yeah
everyone knows the saying everyone is
scared you know frankly shitless of
deploying it because you are increasing
the risk of loss of capital if you're
wrong yep but you are increasing the
probability of outpacing the returns if
you're right oh my god well look ex-post
it's the easiest saying in the world it
is so easy after the fact to say oh
concentration builds well of course you
should have put all your money in Amazon
course but I should put all your money
in Apple Apple at $7 when people were
saying it was going to zero because they
had nothing new and no real competitive
advantage and Microsoft was kicking
their ass that was tough to hold on it's
single digits and what's interesting
about about that point pop is that if
you think about I love this screen so we
can pop our peas on the podcast and it
doesn't sound bad but if you think about
this this construct of concentration of
diversification right I spent my life
soon a guy I was talking about in
chapters so chapter one is I work for a
not for profits and I loved it and it
was great and I love the psychic income
of getting up every morning and going in
and and knowing that we're making
you know Faculty's lives better and
students lives better and the
university's better and and that was
great and then chapter 2 was building
Morgan Creek and building this asset
management business and chapter 3 is
what we're doing together and more Creek
and then chapter 4 is I'll teach but
what's interesting is if you think about
what most people think about me is they
they think about me as this endowment
investment guy it's all about
diversification and what are you talking
about this concentration thing and I'm
like no it what you're missing is again
what I've learned about great great
investors they're those those top-tier
investors is their ability to do a
couple things one is the willingness to
concentrate to being visionary to see
where the puck is headed you know that
ever says it's Wayne Gretzky it wasn't
Wayne it was actually his dad is that
people had why is Wayne so great as well
because he skates to where the puck is
going to be not to where the puck is it
was actually the dad and the key is that
those are those are requisite skills to
be a great investors you have to be
visionary you have to to see the next
thing you have to get out of in front of
it and you have to be willing to double
up but but one of the things that's
really really important is you have to
be willing to be wrong and so many
people are paralyzed at the thought of
being wrong and Twitter's full of this
right people go back and still search
through my Twitter feed and say you were
wrong a year and a half ago when you
said this man what are you talking about
of course I was wrong I'm wrong all the
time but I don't stay wrong being wrong
is fine staying wrong is not and so
great investors are wrong way more than
bad investors because bad investors
don't act they're so paralyzed at the
fear of being wrong that they don't make
investments and so they can't be wrong
but a great investor keeps trying things
keeps pushing the envelope and when
they're wrong they fix it immediately
right they do the Soros admit they're
wrong move on to the next idea because
they've always got great ideas the key
is if if you don't have lots of great
ideas all the time well then you're not
doing it right
right you should cost it be looking and
reading and thinking and talking to
people and looking for great ideas and
and pushing that envelope and keep
trying them all and one things I love
about venture capital investing is you
what zeros right you want to put money
into something and lose it all people
what are you talking about that's not
what a fiduciary doesn't like oh of
course it is because if I make ten
investments and three of them go to zero
and five hundred just in but two of them
make 10 20 30 40 50 X I win and so that
ability to be wrong to be comfortable
being wrong - I say it all the time is
my wife has said you know that I'm
frequently wrong never in doubt I'm like
well occasionally wrong never in doubt
definitely never in doubt and he was a
lot out in fact my wife's only seen me
speak one time and I speak a lot and I
give speeches all over the world and
I've done it for years and and so she
finally came was at a conference in in
Vegas and she came and she sat in the
back and at the end of the speech she
comes with shoes oh my god you can't say
things like that I say things like what
he says you say things with such
conviction like you're sure I well
what's wrong with that shows what people
believe you know that's actually kind of
the idea but what if you're wrong I'm
like well then i'll change my mind so
strong opinions loosely held if you
don't have strong opinions if you don't
have conviction if you don't have
courage you won't act if you don't act
you can't win if you make if you act and
you're wrong then fix it yeah and then
go to the next thing and how do you get
conviction you do the work most people
don't want to do the work right they
want to hear about a good idea they want
to hear a great lesson in life right we
all learn from our mistakes more than
our our successes in fact I keep on my
desk right right on my desk it's a
little thing it says failure changes for
the better success for the worse from
Seneca the younger and it's so true
right when you're successful you get
lazy because you think it's you and then
you get caught off guard you get smashed
when you fail you learn and another good
friend of mine great hedge fund manager
out in California has a great line says
with every investment we get
or wiser never both because you don't
get wiser when you're right you only get
wiser when you're wrong and when you
recognize that mistake you acknowledge
that mistake you learn from it and then
you forget about it that Ralph fearing
that Dean Smith used to talk about so
you know recognize it admit it learn
from it forget it and I had this this
first job so I'm working at this
discipline Investment Advisers we have
billion dollars and people calling us
all the time and the brokers are giving
us hot stock tips and so I had just
gotten my rollover 401k from my first
job and I had you know a few thousand
dollars and I was gonna be a big swinger
and you know instead of doing what I
should so I grew up in Seattle and a
bunch of my friends don't work anymore
because they went to work for this
little company called Microsoft now if
you've ever seen the picture of the
original seven you wouldn't have gone to
work with those guys they look like
freaks but I should have gone to work
there like some of my friends but I
didn't and so here it is 1991 you know I
had this money all I had to do is buy
Microsoft Cisco Intel a couple of other
tech companies out of it said no no no
no this broker calls up he's got to spot
stock tips and the the receptionist
calls says hey you know Joe says you
should you should buy these two
companies I'm like okay so I take half
my 401k distribution I put it in one
company I put the other half
concentration I had done no work I'd
done no homework I didn't know this guy
from Adam but I was in this no new job
and this guy had to be smart no he
didn't have to be smart he was trying to
sell [ __ ] and long story short obviously
I lost my ass now what's great is one of
the stocks literally went to zero the
cool thing about the broker that I used
when you when something goes to zero
they don't take it off your statement so
every month when I opened up my
statement it was still there it was a
great reminder don't ever do that again
don't ever take a hot stock tip do the
work and but I learned so much from that
experience about if you're gonna take
concentrated positions if you're going
to focus on an area do your own work
find people who have have real expertise
in the area and and then follow them
don't take lost octaves so I want to
talk about as part of doing that work
this idea of innovation that's an asset
class and you know I think that what it
really is saying is tying a lot of these
ideas together of innovation is the
things that are being built today that
will eventually become the trend later
right and so it's very early
opportunities to get in front of things
where the innovation is yeah and so this
idea of innovation as an Asif I say be
describe a little bit about what you
mean by that and how people should think
about that as as they think about
investing and in portfolio construction
well you know I've talked about this a
lot in that you're sorry for asset
classes you can oh right there are
stocks bonds currencies and commodities
and everybody else talks about all these
other things you know what about venture
capital what about private equity what
about hedge funds I'm like no at the end
of the day I own a stock a bond currency
or come on let's take private equity in
private equity do I own common stock
preferred stock or convertible bond what
about real estate well I own the equity
of the deal of the debt of the deal or
the land the commodity what about hedge
funds
well hedge funds mutual funds private
partnership separate accounts they own
stocks bonds currencies and commodities
I mean the hedge funds just a legal
structure just like a mutual fund it's a
legal structure so I came up this idea
of innovation as an asset class which is
antithetical to what I just said in the
sense of well no if you're gonna invest
in innovation you're they're gonna own a
stock a bond currency or a commodity
true but but the idea of innovation as
an asset class is basically saying that
I want to focus on owning and most I'm
going to own equity I might know some
convertible debt but I want to own ideas
and I want to own the future and I want
to own big secular trends
over the long term and and and when I
came to this was again I've been blessed
to have great mentors and and have great
relationships and really hang out with
some of the best investors on the planet
and when you when you watch what they do
if you look at the best performing funds
over the years they share a couple
common traits one is they have very high
weighting and private investments so
they take advantage of the liquidity
premium the second is they have a high
weighting in venture capital so what is
venture capital venture capital is is
allocating capital to entrepreneurs who
are gonna build something and it could
be any number of things but they're
pursuing ideas or pursuing business
models they're pursuing innovation and
so as I experienced over time you know
start with bonds and bonds are just a
you know lending money to somebody and
you you you get a small fee for that and
and it's a nice safe investment it's
actually a horrible investment for a
young person you know in fact I actually
say it should be against the law for
people under 40 to own bonds come back
to that later but don't you need guests
so long like just trust me on that one
you should own no bonds because the bond
is really your future income stream
think of that as fixed income over your
life and you can oh bonds later when
you're retired the second is that you
know equity is a claim on the cash flows
of a business and that's what makes it
great but what you really want to own is
the innovation behind the business
that's gonna build new assets or new
industries or and it it can be things
that are little e entrepreneurial or big
e entrepreneurial you have a great line
that that I stole for years and and
people heard me talk about this that
what I love about spending time together
is from the very beginning when we
didn't know each other that well I say
it's like talking to myself right I mean
everything you do on Twitter I like it's
like wait I would have said that wait I
might have said something like that it's
scary it's tough I said
but I always say it's like talking to a
younger better-looking version of myself
but what's cool is I stole this this
line that you talked about that
technology or innovation can can do two
things right it can it can make an old
thing better or it can make something
totally new
Oh biggie entrepreneurship making
something new that's freaking hard I
mean it's really hard there are certain
people who do it and there a lot of
people have done it there are a lot of
ways to capitalize on it and make a lot
of money from it but literally
entrepreneurship you making old things
better is actually not as hard and you
know so I when I when I first started
thinking about leaving the University
and starting a new business you know
it's trepidatious and people say well
mark you're such an entrepreneur I'm
like buy chips what are you talking
about I've worked in the safe
environment I work for not-for-profits
my whole life I am I'm the least
entrepreneurial person on the planet are
you kidding me you created a management
company you spun out of the university
you built two offices you helped build
notre dame's office
you're totally an entrepreneur said okay
I'm a little a entrepreneur I loved
buildings but I don't want to try to
invent things that's that's not my thing
but it's the one thing I think I've said
see before is you know I spent most of
my life technology startups in that
world and as I've learned more about the
wall street asset management kind of
Finance world
if you look around every single person
who is you know one of these world-class
entrepreneurs they don't call themself
entrepreneurs right they're all
investors right that every single one of
them has the identification of I'm an
investor I'm an investor I'm an investor
but you look and you say you built a
business that has you know hundreds if
not thousands of employees right or you
know 50 employees and you've got all
these assets and you built a company it
just might not look like a software
based company right or it might not look
like a restaurant or something like that
but it is a company you did start it and
you did build it and you know you can
call yourself whatever you want today
you started a company right and then
it's just one little nuance of the two
industries where you
you would never find a tech entrepreneur
and building a FinTech to say they were
an investor their founder it's really
it's a great insight again and and and
so true and and it it really helped me
when I you know got over this hump of
thinking about it and like that's a no
thing that's funny someone said to me
once you're a great salesman Mike I am
NOT a Salesman I'm an investor and like
no you're a really great salesman I
think no I am NOT a Salesman I am an
investor and he said well no you're just
looking at it wrong he said sales is
simply transferring your enthusiasm to
another my oh dang I am actually pretty
good at that I can get enthusiastic
about stuff and I can make other people
enthusiastic and and that's ultimately
how you build stuff is you harness
enthusiasm and you get other people
excited and you bring them along but
this again this goes back to this idea
of innovation and and whether it was
Glenn understanding the innovation that
was occurring inside Google and that it
was a better way to do search in a
better way to look it's a verb I mean
think about it right it didn't exist in
1996 and now it's a verb then I use
every single day
crazy crazy and so that's really
astonishing and and the wealth that's
been created by it and that's why I get
so excited about blockchain technology
and Bitcoin and and all the things that
I'm sure we'll talk about at some point
but I I just I have never lacked for
enthusiasm about what I do one because I
get to interact with such great people
too because I'm constantly exposed to
these new ideas and these things that
that literally are changing the world
and change the world for the better
sometimes you know a little little less
less for the better if they get abused
or not used properly but I just find so
much intellectual stimulation and
challenge in trying to intuit one where
Huck is going you know what what
cyclical or secular trends should we be
focused on you know what what area of
innovation should we be focused on and
then how to get that innovation into our
portfolio and I just give two quick
examples so if you think about most
people would tell you if you have some
who's the best investor in the country
the CEO David Swensen Yale number one
it's actually number three that's not
taking anything away David he's amazing
and Dean talk for three is pretty good
and you know Dean Takahashi who's been
the number two it you know that no one
ever talks about you know it's I always
feel sorry for Caufield & Byers you know
kleiner perkins because no one knows
Caulfield Meyers
but they're really good investors and
but it's kleiner perkins or sometimes
even kleiner and then I talk about
Perkins I think what they were all
really good
so Dean Takahashi doesn't get mentioned
or but Yale is pretty good and they've
got 52% in private and they've got 17%
in venture and innovation and that's
fantastic but the number two performing
fund was actually Jeremy Grantham
contrary to my board chairman saying
he's never right his foundation and his
asset allocation is even more simple 40%
hedge funds as a fixed income
replacement 20% emerging market equity
because that's where all the growth is
and 40% venture capital think about that
40% venture capital and it's because he
believes in innovation as an asset class
but the best performing fund is neither
one of those it's a firm called the
Dietrich foundation and their asset
allocation goes back to the investment
community should be an odd number and
three is too many the guy said I'm the
investment committee so I don't have to
argue with anybody I'm gonna put 15% 1/5
in cash to fund two years of spending
and then 85 percent in private and the
bulk of that is gonna be in venture and
growth equity and 25 of the 85 points
are gonna be in China so Chinese private
investments is 25% it was like oh my
gosh that's so risky not risky at all
okay it's where the growth is he's doing
proven business models that you know
make tons and tons of money but most
people perceive risk incorrectly in that
they here china the here risk they here
venture capital here risk well it's only
risky if you did one thing right if I
made one venture investment in China
that's pretty risky if I made one
venture investment United States pretty
risky but if I have a whole portfolio of
innovation I'm gonna have great outcomes
for sure
I want to go through a couple of
thoughts that you have I'm cheating
because I know you well enough to know
that the buttons that hit here but we'll
go through a couple of these and then
we'll get to Bitcoin and crypto the
first is inflation steals wealth from
the poor now mark could talk about this
for hours yeah sure but look I I told
the story about you know
the creature from Jekyll Island and and
why the Fed was created basically to
enrich banks and steal well from the the
second part of that is it's created to
steal wealth from the poor in the middle
class because what are you talking about
you know it saves us no it doesn't so
the idea that inflation is a good thing
and we've been sold a bill of goods over
years that inflation is a good thing
what means you know my incomes rising or
I get a raise every year or get a
cost-of-living adjustment well yeah
that's fine but what it's really
designed to do is to inflate the value
of assets real assets real estate stocks
etc the problem is forty nine percent of
people in this country don't own any
assets half the people in this country
couldn't raise four hundred dollars for
an emergency so they don't own the
assets that are being inflated by this
mythical devaluation of our currency so
just to give everyone who's listening a
quick kind of context here there are two
ways that this forty-nine percent are
essentially affected by inflation one is
they don't have something called a wage
adjust or an inflation adjusted wage
contract which basically means if you
have a job that you're working and every
year you get a raise that's about two
percent three percent whatever it is
what they're essentially doing is
they're increasing your salary enough to
mitigate the effect of inflation if you
happen to work let's say at an hourly
job that doesn't have this inflation
adjustment
you're getting paid the same amount so
let's just say $10 an hour tech
knowledge an hour every year year after
year the problem is that actually you're
getting paid less on a purchasing power
basis because you're ten dollars that
hour that you worked is it can buy you
less and less goods over time so you
think you're getting paid the same but
it's slowly devaluing away the currency
they're getting paid that's one two is
what marks talking about which is that
49% they have no real assets so they
don't own anything they actually leave
their wealth and cash mainly because I'm
living paycheck to paycheck and so what
inflation does is it frankly just
ravages their wealth because it is being
devalued away and we're talking about it
you know the most developed country in
the world where it's not like we have
hyperinflation but if you go and you
look in the hyperinflation market it's
like let's say you know Venezuela's got
10 million they're sent you're talking
about literally one day you know 10
Bolivia are can go and buy a loaf of
bread
the next day 100 Bolivia are can't buy a
loaf of bread right that the inflation
there is much more obvious because it is
hyperinflation the same thing happens in
the u.s. with inflation it's just not as
obvious because the the numbers are
smaller
well we're boiling the Frog right it's
still back to science right if you put a
frog in water and it's hot he'll jump
out if you crank it up a couple degrees
it's like a bath by the time he wants to
jump out he can't because his muscles
don't work so the same things happening
to us we're being boiled like frogs and
that the Fed was created to to create
this inflation and inflation said Rob's
wealth because what it's doing is this
devaluing the currency from 1776 to 1913
a dollar was worth a dollar that
fluctuations up and down recessions Wars
etc but it was basically worth the
dollar today a dollar a hundred plus
years later hundred six years later is
worth about you know three and a half
cents so it'd be 98 percent decrease in
purchasing power from 1913 been devalued
all this amount and it because it's
happening slowly people don't really
observe it and so when people talk about
well you know we can fix income
inequality and wealth inequality and we
just need to cut interest rates again
and we just need to stimulate the
economy more much
no cutting a trace doesn't stimulate the
economy you know QE doesn't stimulate
the economy
what stimulates the economy is job
creation whereas job creation occur
small businesses not big businesses we
didn't need to cut taxes for the super
big companies that's all bogus something
called stealth QE it's a way to
financially engineer higher stock prices
for the rich people we'll get to that in
a second and just so the flipside of the
inflation is there's basically 50/50
split in the country right so you have
the bottom half who is inflation is
absolutely crushing their wealth the
other 50% they own the real assets yeah
and so if you're going to inflate the
asset prices winds up happening is they
actually are getting wealthier at the
expense of the bottom 50% because their
wealth is not stored in cash that's
stored in these real assets the real
asset prices go up and literally the
inflation they like it because it is
making their purchase yeah and and the
top 1% owns the vast majority of those
assets so they love it and they're the
ones that control a government by
placing the people in power who they
want in power and I make the the joke
today that you know there's no Democrats
Republicans no left no right they're
just in and out when you're in power you
do or say whatever it takes to stay in
and when you're out of power you do or
say whatever it takes to get in and and
that's the way we've gone is we have
Republicans in charge tea party
Republicans in charge and we just
created the biggest deficit in history
forget Republicans Democrats left-right
it's just in out and what that does is
if the 1% controls the government you
know absolute power corrupts absolutely
what we're gonna get is a corrupt
environment and this this stealing of
wealth from that middle class and that
has used a decimation of the middle
class and so talk to me a little bit
about the relationship between how
inflation works and the interest rate
cuts in the QE basically the two tools
that central banks have whenever we get
towards recessive periods but cut rates
they print more money which is now I
love the term we use of the new abnormal
the new abnormal yes so maybe talk a
little bit about how that has impacted
asset prices over the last decade or so
and then also really the middle class
it's pretty obvious in terms of the
wealth inequality kind of the inflection
point that's occurred over the last
decade or so yeah I mean the the idea
that if you think about fixing of prices
any type of fixing prices minimum wages
fixed prices in rent control or interest
rates right that's a bad idea the market
should set prices and the price of money
or the price of interest rates should be
set by the markets but know we have this
you know a bunch of stale white guys
that pale stale and and Mail you know
that that that determined although we
did it Janet Yellen so but mostly these
older people who are PhDs and they set
this this price and it's it's very non
transparent it's very based on human
decisions and analysis and as all the
time why would we trust a group of
people and it's not an exaggeration
there been two hundred and forty-four
quarterly estimates of growth issued by
the Fed they're over zero right I could
coin flip and be right half the time
they're over so why would we think that
they are gonna make good decisions on
interest rates policy they're not so
then it makes the assumption that
they're trying to make good decisions
they're not so the idea that the Fed can
stimulate the economy by lowering
interest rates and giving better access
to capital for businesses made sense
when interest rates varied between some
lower bound and some upper bound and you
know we had the craziness of the 70s and
we had the normal period of the you know
40 50 60 s 80's 90's but once you get
below two percent once you get in this
the zero bound of interest rates that
that tool loses its effectiveness and so
raising interest rates didn't slow the
economy as much and slowing and lowering
its trace hasn't stimulated the economy
as much well really what that is is what
people forget is the economy
isn't driven by interest rates it's
driven by people and it's driven by
demographics and demographics are
destiny and you're gonna ask me later I
know you're gonna ask me what's my
favorite most important book and and I
don't want to give one so I'm a weave in
a couple but but one that I think is
really important is this this idea of
Harry dent wrote a book called the great
boom ahead and what's interesting is his
first book is awesome the rest his books
and not so much and I like Harry's a
good guy but people don't like him
because he's been very bearish on the
market and predicting doom and gloom and
but his first book is amazing and in it
he he talks about a couple things that
are really really important one is this
idea that demographics drives everything
and we can tell exactly what's going to
happen in a society based on the number
of 25 to 45 year old people the number
of 45 to 65 year old people the number
of 65 to 85 year old people when you
have 25 to 45 year old people you have
low productivity and high inflation and
that makes sense it's not because young
people aren't smart or nice or good it's
just that they're not trained they're
not highly productive and so you borrow
from your customers in the form of
higher inflation to train your workers
when you're 45 to 65 age cohort
dominates you're going to be really
highly productive you have lots of
spending the maximum spending your life
is age forty six and a half you got the
two kids you got college you got cars
you got vacations you're spending all
this money it's like potato chips you
eat the maximum number of potato chips
when you're 13 you'll never eat more
potato chips in your whole life than
when you were 13 and you'll never spend
more money when you're 46 now so things
happen at certain times your life so
it's not surprising that we had this
great boom when everybody in the US the
baby boomers or turning 45 to 65 now
every day 10,000 people turn 65 every
single day for the next 17 years and
it's no surprise that we have less
productivity and less spending because
turns out 65 to 85 year olds don't spend
a lot and they're not very productive it
doesn't mean they cannot nice people but
the demographics drives everything and
so ultimately that that demographics
can't be trumped by interest rate policy
and so if you look around the world
Japan was first Japan has the oldest
demographics and so they started down
1989 and they've had now you know twenty
nine years thirty years of bad economic
growth low interest rates zero interest
rates and people think that that's not
going to happen to us well it is because
happening in Europe you see almost all
of European debt now is is trading below
zero NERP negative interest rates and US
interest rates despite everybody saying
that the bond bond market was over and
bond prices had to go down and this race
had to go up
I mean yields had to go up exact
opposites happen so demographics is
destiny and the Fed is less omnipotent
in fact this friend of mine has a great
line he says I remember a damn old
enough I remember a day when I didn't
know the names of central bankers I long
for that day to return and so what
they've gone to do is is QE and you know
people think QE is new it's not new we
did it in the 30s
I read Ali over writes about this and
talks about it is in the 30s we had this
thing called the Great Depression and if
you think about the 1930s we were an
emerging market the United States was an
emerging market if you've seen the movie
gangs in New York this was not a good
place to live from 1860 to 1920 it's
kind of rough and you could you know die
walking down the street by 1929 the
Italian gang beat the Irish gang you
know Viva Italia and so now we're a
country run by a single gang but no one
would buy our debt and because
post-world War One and you know we were
in emerging market so no one went over
our debt so we bought our own debt so he
bailed ourselves out and then in 1937 we
had zero interest rates just like today
and we tried to raise rates to 25 basis
points and we turned the Great Recession
into the Great Depression and then it
wasn't until World War two when we were
able to stimulate our way out to get out
of it and so we had this twenty year
period of a really bad nasaw this idea
of QE and zero inch straight bound
and so Fed policy becomes less powerful
and so now you have these central
bankers who they feel powerful right
they're voted time man of the year you
know Ben Bernanke save the real Ben
Bernanke did not save the world China
saved the world right China pumped four
trillion dollars into the global economy
want the u.s. cutting interest rates and
doing QE it was China and so the key
here is we at this point now where
everyone thinks the Fed is invincible
everyone thinks central banks have it
all under control but what we've seen is
it's not working right you had all the
ECB inch straight cuts they're in
recession Japan and straight cuts
negative yields you know Bank of Japan
now owns 75% of Japanese government
bonds and three-quarters of all their
ETFs hasn't worked so us is going down
that path when we talked about I said I
would talk about Stealth QE right
everyone talks about the tax act why do
we do the tax act tax acts had nothing
to do with taxes it had to do with the
Fed my law is prohibited from buying
stocks they bought all the bonds they
could buy and so they need to buy stocks
to try to keep stock market up to keep
the wealth effect going to keep stealing
from the poor and so the government say
hey here's the deal we'll go to the
companies that have a lot of cash Apple
let's said I'll give you all a big tax
cut but you have to promise to buy back
your stock and pump up stock prices so
they're not allowed to do capex they're
not allowed to do investment for the
future and I allowed to invest in
innovation they just gotta buy back
their stock well why is that well
because the people like Warren Buffett
oh and lots of stock so it's all a
circular thing of concentrating the
wealth closer and closer in the top one
percent so I'll call it stealth QE so
now we're at this point where you got
the president browbeating the guy that
he hired right how weird is it that the
guy has hired seven people and then
within months called them incompetent
that's just weird right why would you
tell somebody I would just tell the
world that you hired an incompetent
but maybe the incompetents coming for
someplace else but the key is that you
know Jerome Powell is doing the best he
can in a flawed system because under or
approaching the zero bound monetary
policy stops working what you really
need is fiscal policy or more
importantly what you need is innovation
right it was up to me I would create a
massive venture capital fund funded by
the government funded by Social Security
and I would invest in all the great
entrepreneurs and I would and owned a
piece of what they do wait somebody does
that that's called the government of
Singapore they take their Social
Security money and they invested around
the world with the best entrepreneurs
and they are wildly over funded in their
entitlement programs because they
actually invest instead of using a you
know rob Peter to pay Paul system they
actually invest an investment
particularly investment innovation would
solve all those problems and then we
wouldn't need this you know Ponzi scheme
asked way of you know you keep working
so I can retire we solved that problem
it's a it's pretty crazy when you start
to tie in the history of how this stuff
was created why it was created who
created it you tie in the data of the
impact that it's had and you add in
pretty educated estimates of what is
likely to occur in the future whether
it's demographic or just other examples
around the world you look at a system
that I don't want to call it failing but
it's definitely flawed in many ways and
the part that to me is the most shocking
is one there's incentives whether it's
from the government side or the banking
side to continue the charade right kind
of everyone keep doing what they're
doing because you know hey I'm such a
such a a only got another you know 15 20
years yeah not my problem right a type
of thing at the same time what you see
is
one of my favorite examples to give
people is every disrupter becomes the
man right and I think it's sudden the
vault robber caught at one point he made
the comment that if Bill Gates was a
teenager today he'd be working on
Bitcoin and crypto of course right
because at the time working on Microsoft
was the equivalent of working on Bitcoin
crypto blocks of today and so he has
gone from one of the kind of most fringe
disrupter I'm gonna go and build this
massive company and take on the
incumbents too now he is the man of
course and if you look across a bunch of
these that happens in entrepreneurship
it also happens in politics and I think
part of it is your example of like the
in and out crowd mm-hmm when people are
out and they want to get in there very
disruptive
they're very and it always cracks me up
that once they get in and it's both
sides of the aisle has nothing to do
with the political ideology all of a
sudden the vernacular right the way they
articulate ideas it all gets tempered it
kind of gets to this world let's not
rock the boat as much because now I'm in
the crowd cuz now I might get kicked out
it's like it's like whiteboards make bad
investment decisions what's on the board
now I just want stay on the board it's
like in this group of people in this
room right if I asked what's the best
restaurant in New York the group will
give me McDonald's in America I'll get a
really good answer
but the group will say well I don't want
to tell about this Indian place I know
because he might not like Indian and he
might like American continental food but
it's kind of spite
McDonald's it just gets dumbed down and
that's the same thing happens in
politics as it gets dumbed down back to
this level of I just want to stay here
and but the real problem is is our
friend are the framers set it up as a
voluntary service two years you went
back and ran your family farm and you
couldn't be a lifelong politician the
problem is today is not voluntary it
cost you a hundred million dollars to
become a senator
not very many people have a hundred
million dollars lying around meg Whitman
tried but most people have to raise
money well if you raise a hundred
million dollars you're gonna owe people
stuff and it turns out when you owe
people stuff your mouth and scented is
scented I don't have a lot of opinions
about politics but the one idea and I
forgot forget who who gets credit for
this but the one that I really really
agree with is if you are elected as a
representative I don't care what part of
government what ya ideology you should
not be allowed to participate in the
legislation creation or editing of the
industry that backed you to get there Oh
amen yeah so if the health care you know
if the drug companies put you in you
can't talk about it
participate in any legislation has to do
with drug companies right if it was the
tobacco industry if it was whatever you
just what you start to do is you change
the incentives right and you change the
way that that things are kind of
occurring we're running out of time so
we've got probably about 20 minutes or
so I want to talk I want to talk about
two things well three things because we
have to talk about aliens as well but
the first is real quick in like three
minutes talk about the fact that when
you deposit money in a bank it's not
your money anymore ah again little-known
fact right people put their money in the
bank and they're like okay that's my
money
fact is no it's the bank's money look on
the bank balance sheet it shows up as
their asset and you have an IOU from the
bank
nobodies know but but I can get any time
I want well yeah you can unless they
lose it well how could they lose it I'll
give an example so I met a guy his dad
founded syndicated TV he inherited
almost a billion dollars 960 million
dollars and I said where's your money
since in the bank like what he meets in
the bank so I don't want to lose it like
what you could lose it really easily
because it's not your money anymore says
no no it's insured
I said well it's insured up to 250 K but
not 960 million big Delta between 960
million to 250 yeah and and so make a
long story short he did diversify he put
it in four banks and the sad part is in
the grill for the global financial
crisis while the banks went bust
he lost 25 percent
- the 250 got back from insurance and
people just don't understand whether
it's Cypress literally you wake up one
morning and 75% of your money is gone
because they you know take it because
there's a lil in tax one of my favorite
terms ever a bank levy right which for
an English format all that means is they
literally wet in it so we need to raise
money really fast let's go to the banks
and tell them take 75 50 10 % whatever
the number was per bank just take that
money call it a bank tax and now we've
got the money that we need to go do what
we need look I'm not I'm not a bank
hater in the sense that I actually
believe fractional reserve banking is
what separates the great countries from
the less good countries right if if you
think about if you can make a dollar
work harder by you know fresheners are
lending it that's a it's a wonderful
system but it can be abused and I think
it has been abused and and I think you
know the biggest problem is that we we
don't hold people accountable for their
actions and we bail out the powerful and
instead of letting him fail I mean
Iceland's a good example they let their
banks fail and they didn't go down the
drain there Iceland still around last
time I checked but this idea that that
the money in the bank is not yours is a
fundamental premise that people need to
understand because everybody thinks
about it as no I can go get it at any
time but you can't and it's like stock
right in a brokerage account it's not
yours either like what are you talking
about know your paper stocks tickets
it's a DTCC and then it's registered
through a registration process with the
broker the right that that you you know
work with but you have an IOU from the
broker for that particular stock
certificate and then you get a Q sip
electronic version but you don't have
ownership of the asset which can change
with digital this is all fine when
things are going well it's when things
turn sour that that's real issues of
course all right Bitcoin we've got
almost two hours and haven't talked
about that's why don't you short well
yeah that was my secret goal you and I
and Jason have gone around the country
talked about this get off 0 you unlike
Jason and I have sat on the other side
of the table as a fiduciary managed
these endowments and really kind of
thought through asset allocation etc
just but a couple minutes talking about
how you think about Bitcoin why it's
interesting and how it fits into
somebody's institutional investors
portfolio from a portfolio construction
standpoint yeah I mean we talked earlier
about this idea that that you gotta
focus on innovation we talked about this
idea that you know disruptive technology
is really important and disruptors are
important and if I think back in my
career as a fiduciary I've sat on boards
I've managed portfolios as a fiduciary I
built a business around being a
fiduciary for four clients one of the
things is I've always found myself
hanging out with the fringe with the
disruptors and you know when I first
brought the idea of hedge funds to Notre
Dame they're like I know that's where
all the bad people are I know they're
not bad people they just make a lot of
money because they're really talented
and you know then we wanted people to
invest in distressed debt and the Borsig
oh we can't do junk bonds I hope you do
realize that the bulk of your you know
investment is in equity which is junior
to you know subordinated debt in terms
of claim on cash flows so maybe it's
okay if you own distressed debt even
though you want to call it junk and so
this idea that you want to go where the
disruptors are where the fringe is has
always been pretty important and and
people confuse this idea that that
that's not fiduciary correct and it's
only not fiduciary correct because it's
not accepted custom if you go back to 60
years ago the average endowment
foundation didn't own stocks right it
was all in fixed income and then someone
said wow that's a really bad trade and
then in 1973 there was this idea that
hey maybe we should think about
international diversification and ERISA
came in and suddenly you could do
international stocks and bonds
and so what what seemed outlandish are
crazy then becomes customary and one of
the things I talk about in this this
whole theme and we've talked about
together this this get off zero is ten
years from now you're gonna look back
and everyone's screaming today about how
oh you can't invest in this because it's
a you know not fiduciary proper or it's
it's not an acceptable asset class or a
customary asset class you're gonna look
back is it oh my gosh you are a bad
fiduciary if you didn't invest in this
the same way that you know today if you
don't have hedged assets in your
portfolio you're not a good fiduciary if
you don't have a diversified portfolio
globally you're not a good fiduciary if
you don't think about low correlation
assets you're not a good fiduciary so
all these ideas you know people forget
to the cap em capital asset pricing
model
there's only 75 year old technology you
know it's not like it's multiple
hundreds of years old so all these ideas
about bringing new technology and
innovation and a new area of new areas
of investment into the portfolio what
start out as radical end up as accepted
and the key again is being early and and
taking advantage and you think about you
know why is Yale been great all these
years or Notre Dame or Duke or UNC it's
because they're always out ahead they're
always putting the new asset classes the
new strategies into the portfolio before
everybody else what I think that you
know look when we first started really
talking about this stuff the the one
thing that you said to me that everyone
knows but no one understood I think is
you have to talk to a fiduciary an
institution in their language right and
so where the Bitcoin community is racing
around and screaming and yelling about
you know it's gonna be a new global
reserve currency you don't need a
central bank oh dollar is screwed right
all these things that there's a high
probability are true right
or definitely possible right and some
people are it's definitely possible and
likely probable yeah yeah and so if you
if you kind of say okay that's the way
that you would speak to technologists to
other bitcoiners to people who are
looking for innovation and and kind of
the ideological revolution something
like that institutional investors all
that language they run so far so fast
that it just scares the hell out on I
mean look
so here I am it's six years ago 2013 you
know one of the guys I backed that came
out of julienne shop dan Moorhead he
found a firm called Pantera 1314 years
ago we were first money into his macro
hedge fund and six years ago he calls up
and says hey Mark I'm shutting down the
hedge fund and I'm gonna open up to
funds and in crypto one in Bitcoin and
one in infrastructure like what are you
talking about and I had heard of Bitcoin
I would say I was neither a drug dealer
on Silk Road nor cryptographic
cryptography students so I hadn't really
gotten exposure but I kind of heard
about it and I went out met with him in
San Francisco and you know he went from
a billion dollar fund to 15 one five
million dollars raised for this this
fund and and I had the first of my many
bad decisions in crypto is I could have
gone to Bitcoin fund or the
infrastructure fund I'm at picks and
shovels guy I get picks and shovels I
get infrastructure my good Dan let's do
that I should have gotten a Bitcoin fun
right the pics shows fun up 10x no one's
complaining about 10x awesome great but
the Bitcoin funds up 180 X that was
better
so that's 2008 2013 so my son's getting
ready to graduate from from Notre Dame I
send him out to meet with Dan might go
work at coinbase or Zappo or something
and just get in the industry and you
know get in front of the trend and and
he goes out he meets with Dan of a
couple companies and he comes back says
yeah dad I yeah I'm not sure I think I'm
just go with KPMG and it's safe they'll
get me to San Francisco where I want to
be and we got a chuckle out of it last
Thanksgiving it's like I find dad you
were right but you're not as smart as
you think you are Michael
what do you mean of course I'm smart
what do you mean he says no you didn't
lever up the house and by bikal like
good point but here's the crazier thing
so first quarter of 2015
you know Bitcoin has dropped from a
thousand bucks down to five hundred and
I wrote one paragraph in these crazy
long corny letters that I used to write
you know 40 50 60 pages 41 page letter
one paragraph about Bitcoin as a special
situation thinking it's good investment
okay this first quarter 2015 $500 I had
people call up and say will fire you if
you don't stop talking about this crazy
stuff wow that's an extreme reaction and
there was just fear there's fear of this
new technology of this crazy magic
internet money you know the bad guys and
the mount gox's and the you know Silk
Roads and just stop talking about now
you went from 500 to 175 bucks by
September oh my god maybe they're right
no they weren't right so then it zooms
back to a thousand and now I'm back on
it I get some our clients into it and I
get some of our people excited about it
we do some more infrastructure and we
start thinking about maybe we should do
something here and another year goes by
and still haven't done a lot but we've
got we've got people invested we've got
a little bit and then theorem comes
along we got a little bit of interest in
that again not as much as novo and
others but we got people to kind of get
off zero but what was interesting is is
I hadn't really had the big epiphany yet
and you know the you and I met briefly
you know 20 minutes in our conference
room talking about lift as I believe is
letting me in the office
Maurice got this nice office in Chapel
Hill I came in at a t-shirt and a
baseball cap and I was like I think that
I might under dress for this one well
and it works right cuz you were that guy
from California who just left snap and
and moved back home and and kind of had
the myth and legend of the Facebook time
and so there's just this kind of yeah
it's just nice nice to meet you but we
didn't spend that much time exciting I
didn't get it yet and
you know about maybe three or four
months later you did actually we're on
up doing a podcast you did a podcast
with O'Shaughnessy apeture croissants
yeah Patrick Shaughnessy and it wasn't
even that long it's like 25 minute
podcast and you know Shaughnessy
Patrick's a Notre Dame guy gyms and
Notre Dame Guide and so I listened to
the podcast I say it's interesting guy
we need to meet oh wait I did meet him
give me his contact info and and you
know I I sent you guys such a direct
message on Twitter because you know I
started following you and it was I said
like like like like this weird it's like
everything coming on your mouth is
something I would have would have said
and we got together for breakfast and
you know my famous line about a morning
person and you showed up early and you
had your coffee and and we got talking
then we had breakfast again the next day
and then a couple days later and it
became very clear very quickly that
there was something here and it was
something we needed to focus on together
yeah and I think part of it is when you
go and you talk to these institutions
right and you told me that early on hey
look this is likely gonna be interesting
but not interested type relationship or
conversation and what I realized was in
a number of those early conversations I
had the same experience that pretty much
I think every fund manager in the space
had where people just didn't get it
mmm the second that you and I sat down
and and Jason and I really were like hey
okay well what about this what about
this what about that you know hey this
is why we were excited about it whatever
you very quickly said okay don't use
that word right use this word hey don't
talk about like you know taking down the
financial system yeah maybe talk about
like a non-correlated asymmetric ass
yeah and you really learn that oh wait a
second you're saying the exact same
thing you know you're now saying it in a
different language that resonates and
kind of checks these mental boxes for an
institutional investor and when you do
that what you give them is less to worry
about and you give them a much cleaner
kind of framework to evaluate the
opportunity and I joke all time when I
said the idea of a non-correlated
asymmetric asset to 99% of people the
world means nothing mm-hmm when you show
that with data to an institutional
investor they have to pay attention have
to right and they'll argue with you the
qualitative nature if it's sustainable
in all these kind of nuances but just
that one thing it is this trigger that
kind of flips them over from I'm not
interested to I have to be interested
let's see what happened well you're
exactly right it and and again it's it's
why we've been great partners as we feed
off each other and the ideas and and to
your point you know back to my first
mistake with my board right 40
recommendations no no no no no no no
these were observations don't threaten
them so don't go in to an institution
saying hey this thing's gonna take down
the financial system because oh by the
way 100% of my assets are in the
financial system I don't I don't want to
hear that so what I do want to hear is
okay technology has progressed and I
this is something that you know became
very clear for me I was like this aha
moment this Eureka moment that you know
I've been investing in this technology
cycl 54 mainframe 68 microchip 82
personal computer 96 Internet 2010
mobile net and now 2024 the trust net my
term use it frequently but people walk
off the internet of value or the
Internet of Things or whatever it is or
the blockchain era but it became very
clear that that as Doss was to operating
system for PCs iOS and Android or the
operating system for handhelds and now
we're gonna have this operating system
for the Internet of value and that is
going to be blockchain technology and I
did have this epiphany moment I even
wrote about it you know from Eureka
California that I had this Eureka moment
and like oh my gosh we have to do this
together and we have to build and and
you have to do it because it's way
better coming from you is you know you
very successful guy lost it back on and
I it's amazing I had all the
question I was gonna ask you and I
didn't do any of it but give me this
dude give the story of why did you and
Jason decide to partner with us you know
stodgy staid institutional firm I always
used the example of like a Venn diagram
right which was we had Justin I have
investing in federal micro VC style into
a bunch of these companies can't start
out are we good at this okay we might be
good at this okay I think that actually
we can go find a lot of these deals
let's go raise more money the
institutional world's interesting you
and I started talking I always joke with
Jason and said I tricked mark because
Mark was learning from me about crypto
he didn't realize I was learning about
the institutional good trick good trade
I think that in those conversations what
became very obvious was we had talked to
a bunch of people in kind of the
institutional asset management world and
they were all bankers right now used
bankers that's like kind of a a banner
title that is not a negative title it's
just a they come from the traditional
financial world they're training the
traditional financial world that's how
they think that's how they act that's
who they surround themselves with and
it's a very specific mindset on the
other side you have all the crypto folks
right all the Bitcoin folks who are just
hardcore you know decentralized Network
nology very innovative a very disruptive
etc and when you bring together those
two separate buckets of people in the
kind of a Venn diagram the overlap is
actually a really really small set of
people who come from the institutional
asset management world understand kind
of traditional finance markets asset
allocation portfolio construction and
also understand innovation disruption
right technology etc obviously you've
been talking about about a lot of those
things today and so in that bucket there
was even a small group literally one
which was you Morgan Creek that I think
aligned with us in terms of you're not a
traitor right and you're not gonna go
out and hedge fund and in the sense of
let's go pick stocks and you know trade
you're not going to just long passive
index right there's a very specific kind
of equity
you know ben-tor bias and more venture
capital private equity type
infrastructure etc and so you know very
early on I remember having two specific
investment thesis which was hey bitcoins
interesting as this idea of an algorithm
is gonna store value for people I'd you
know I can I've said this on my podcast
million times and now that marks here I
can say it I'll say it when Jason's here
as well I'm 31
Jason's mid 40s to mid 50s and when you
put that together it becomes a really
interesting collection of experiences
and perspectives because I can sit there
and say trust me there's a whole group
of people like me who are gonna trust
this algorithm to secure their value
right their wealth and while that's
weird too you know somebody who's
sitting there saying look I've been dead
for 30 years and there's no freaking way
somebody's not gonna put their money in
a bank right and then this actually
there's a lot of people like Nazis right
I think that that's a really kind of
beneficial thing and the second thing
was this every stock bond currency and
commodity was gonna get digitized and I
think that you know kind of the
historical perspective of the shifts
already happened before from the analog
electronic world electronic digital it
just made a lot of sense of there was
things that you guys brought to the
table that we had no clue about not not
even that we couldn't do just we had no
clue about and I think vice-versa
there's things that we brought to the
table that you guys were like look we
kind of heard about it but you know
helped accelerate this I mean that's
again to make about youth and an age did
you know look you get wise as you get
older but just because you've made
mistakes and you survive it's like it's
like the firefighter who says you know
they hey he has a sixth sense
no he just fell through a lot of floors
and didn't die so now he knows to touch
the door and before he goes in and he's
got he's wise and so but with what that
wisdom becomes this in transience about
oh no no one would not have a bank
account or a brokerage account well do
you know I know people who don't have
either of those and have 80 plus percent
of their assets in crypto and actually
you know I think about it that's
actually not illogical given where we're
headed and so what was great for me was
was again that epiphany of saying
and one plus one plus one is five or ten
or more as as the three of us together
created this this asymmetric upside
potential in terms of building a new
venture that took all the benefit and
all the wisdom and all the experience
and all the relationships and all the
knowledge that we had for 15 years or
more and Creek to then kind of lasso
this shooting star that we want to ride
along with that is going to be this new
asset class in this this new fiduciary
standard or the Bitcoin standard that's
coming and and you know I said the the
interesting thing for me was also
there's a if you go back in history all
of the great intellectual and
technological innovations come from
young people Marc Andreessen was not a
55 year old guy when he invented the
browser he's doing great stuff now too
as an older guy but but the youth is is
you know where this comes from and I say
Bill Gates you know he got mistaken as
the coffee boy by IBM right IBM passed
on the Microsoft the first time because
they thought he was the coffee boy it's
better than coffee boy but youth is
Israel were saddened and that the most
I've had more fun in the last two years
then I probably had in the last 21
because I get to hang out with young
people who are enthusiastic and and and
really doing interesting things and and
while I can't keep up the pace right I
used to think I worked hard until I
started you know working out with you
and you know I I love the fact that I am
reverse aging I'm becoming less rigid
and things that I thought were
absolutely true and I'm going back to
that wonder I had look when I was the 34
year old as a CIO of a university and
people's like what the hell you how'd
you get that job and it goes back again
I pick on my board chair from UNC but he
was actually an amazing guy and he's
very successful and he had a great line
when I asked him I said you know why why
did why'd you pick me says I've never
hire anybody over 35
like why not and he says ah because the
way it works in this world is your 20s
or forgetting educated your 30s or for
building your reputation your 40s or for
capitalizing on your reputation your 50s
and 60s or for enjoying your reputation
and so by 35 you don't want to work hard
and I need people to work hard wow
that's really interesting and there is
this the sense of wonder this sense of
of potential achievement and and
motivation and and I feel like I've got
reinvigorated and have it again so I I
clearly AM not 35 again but but I feel
like it plus I have an eight-year-old to
prove it so I think that combination of
youthful enthusiasm and a sense of
understanding of that generational shift
along with a business builder like Jason
who you'll talk about on the next pot
and and my experience in in building
asset management business comes together
to do something really special I agree I
agree it's real or not the concept of
aliens definitely real okay the idea
that we're alone in this in this you
know series of universe is impossible
the idea that aliens have visited this
planet I'm not there I think the
boundary with that my thing is that like
the last the last week I've been laying
in my backyard staring up at the sky
trying to find the Perseids and it just
ticks me off that we had a full moon
right at the meteor shower peaks I
couldn't see as many as I wanted to but
when you're sitting up looking at the
Stars it it's kind of again it's fills
you with the sense of wonder and when
you when you look at you know one of the
sky apps on your phone and you see just
the gazillions of stars and and
universes and you think no way we could
be alone so mathematically you know
combination of things you need for life
but I think it would take a different
form and a different format but the idea
that
that you know little green men have
landed on this an area 51 or stored
there I'm not there don't buy it I think
that that is probably the most
intellectually sound way that people
look at it is life probably exists
somewhere from mathematical basis they
probably doesn't probably look and you
know act the way that we see it in
movies and if it's anywhere it's like in
an area 51 type thing but unlikely that
my thing is space travel is just too
hard yeah maybe I did so in a great line
yesterday and I saw on Twitter said if
there were a planet that was 51 million
light years away I don't know why they
picked that number and they could
actually see here they'd see dinosaurs
like okay yeah that puts it in
perspective that you know Star Trek like
I I had you know one of my Twitter
moments was you know William Shatner
added me like wow that's kind of cool
because I grew up you know watching the
guy and the idea of Star Trek you know
going from plant no it's just not
happening colonizing Mars not happening
pretty good not not let me go down the
Tesla revver
for I'll let you ask me one question to
end this but just for the record mark is
a is a Tesla Bear and I have a Tesla
bowl and we have a very spirited to say
all right well always have the same
opinion one is unnecessary very true
what uh what one question do you have
for me
I told you you're only gonna get one
question this whole time I have so many
but the one is in one of things I really
admire about you is is your your
commitment to everything you do I mean
you are you are all in one percent of
time and one of things that had to be
just devastating in some ways and
challenging and others was you know
basically being disrupted
in the middle of college to go off to
the army but what was the one thing you
took away from that experience so the
all end thing there's a saying as kids
we my brothers and I and then a number
of our friends used to joke about but
there's you know in every great joke
there's a hint of truth type thing is
anything worth doing it's worth
overdoing
mm-hmm now we used to use it as kids of
like oh well if it's worth eating ice
cream just eat the whole bucket you can
always you could apply that as a kid to
basically piss off your parents but but
I do think that there's a lot of truth
in that and things in life and if you
use that as a filter you start to change
some of the things that are worth doing
right and so when I went to Iraq I'd
signed up basically for like this
reserve contract and then I'd go
sometime after college I'm a junior I
had known that it was a possibility but
very small they call and Mike I'd kind
of not paid attention so it's like oh if
I don't pay attention to the possibility
banana - it's like the ostrich turned
his back on the Lions yeah and so all of
a sudden they said hey in one week you
have to report it as I oh that's like
real and so I went and for me I was 20
and I was joke and say I went to basic
training when I was 17 they were yelling
and screaming at me anyone that was like
over the age of like 25 they had enough
self-respect to realize like why are you
treating me like this
at 17 I was like oh you're nicer to me
they're like the football coach was so
you're kind of just in you're at that
time of your life you're used to
everyone yelling your parish to your
coaches yell it to your teachers
knowledge it's all whatever when I went
at 20 I was too dumb to realize how
dangerous it was because you kind of
think like you're Superman right it's
just like yeah like this is gonna be fun
which is really weird now you look back
you know literally it's 11 years later
and I'm like whoa like that was pretty
crazy but the other piece of it was I
was there with a bunch of older guys so
I think that like the average age was
like 28 or something which was very
uncommon so this isn't kind of the
active army this will
as a reserve unit so the guys are a
little bit older they've been in for
longer and it was weird at first to go
from like the 20 year old playing
football in college and like what's the
party on Friday night you know or
Saturday night after the game to the
dude who's sleeping next to me literally
like 6 inches away on a cot
he's talking about his mortgage yeah or
his kids at home right are with it and
what you realize is like you just get
this crash course and when I came back
is when I noticed the the big difference
cuz all some of the things I had cared
about before I went really didn't matter
it's like where's the party at
right but what it taught me was uh the
idea that like the people you surround
yourself with you very quickly adapt to
rate and and and kind of your mindset
changes to that and it wasn't so much
like oh they were great investors or
entrepreneurs or you know anything that
like the business world cares about it
was the fact that they had really these
guys were from like the backwoods of
Pennsylvania yep
did good values that real lives yeah and
there was no kind of like you know the
Travis came on the podcast em you sort
[ __ ] hurry right it was just like this
is life okay and so when you're
surrounded with that for a year you kind
of grew up pretty quickly and you
realize like hey there's a pretty clear
line here of like the things that matter
things that don't matter it's when I
came back all like everything changed
right so it was very much for me uh
unaccelerated I grew up yes it was
dangerous situation but when you get
back and you kind of survive that Nelson
you're like hey man it's like a new
lease on life type thing you don't see
here people who go to jail people who
are in your life this situation or near
death situations you know they all kind
of the same takeaway of just like just
live life to the fullest or kind of
anything worth doing but I think they're
real the real thing for me in listening
to dude
give that answers is the who you
surround yourself with and I talk about
this all time is look at the five people
you spend the most time with that is who
you'll become absolutely choose wisely
and I think that's why why choosing your
partners is important why choosing your
associates is important your spouse your
significant other all those things are
critically important and it's a great
way I could
I could agree with it more and I think
that it's people know that it's really
really hard to execute until they get in
a situation and then when you get in the
situation you know that the thing I'll
leave everyone with is uh when Jason
myself and Mark decided to work together
I remember we walked out of the Morgan
Creek offices and I said what did you
think and he literally said to me he
goes we just jumped from high school to
the pros yeah and I always remind myself
of you know there's an element of your
force to raise your level of effort your
level of your game etc when you surround
yourself with that and so same reason
you know why do all these MBA
guys that are stars they're kids and
being really good at basketball
cuz they're playing with NBA players
every day yeah yeah kind of accelerates
the things that you do say no it's been
why at that point and I know we're
running out of time but you didn't ask
and and but I do want to talk about it
real quickly is most important book and
yeah it's such a tough question and I
was joked that you know my wife reads
more books in a month than I read my
whole life it's not read many books I
read so much for work and I just don't
read books but the one book that I that
I have read that I do think is a life
changer and it it has a little bit to do
with why we're together and doing this
is the alchemist and what it talks about
is this idea of a personal legend and
you know knowing what your destiny is
and pursuing it and and a friend gave it
to me at the right time you know things
happen for a reason of course and I read
at the right time and it was just all
the things that that went into it and
and there's there's a line in there that
I love which is you know if you if you
really wish for something if you really
want something to happen the universe
will conspire to make it so and and I
think this is a great example of that
that I I knew I was interested in
blockchain and Bitcoin and crypto and
and I knew there was something there but
the universe had to conspire to bring
you and I together and then to bring
Jason in to to to give us the
opportunity to create more Greek digital
and and to change our business model
right from from fund to funds to direct
investment
from major managers and public markets
to really focusing on venture capital
and innovation and to get me to to kind
of revert back to my entrepreneurial
let's build this and and and also in
that conspireing it's it's getting you
guys to conspire against me and in a
positive way of saying hey you know
let's sharpen the edge and let's you
know let's not focus on stuff that isn't
as important or can't make as much a
difference and let's focus on what's
really important and and that's been
good and so whereas a book people think
can't make a big difference sometimes
but in many ways that single book or the
single idea can can make a huge
difference and then and then one throw
into best investment book is a book all
the Dow Jones averages and Dow spelled
ta oh and it's a mixing of ancient
Chinese philosophy and investing and
when it talks about is most investors
are too left brained you know right
handed analytical backward looking and
and the best investors are whole brained
and they have to have that creative side
and that ability to see things
differently and there's a whole part
about you know why women are better
investors it's called women intuition
for for a reason and I was listening to
your your pod the other day with Sierra
Moochie and I was listening to the one
with Novogratz and and you know one
things that they talk about a lot is
this idea you know intuition and
trusting that intuition and my intuition
on you
Jason on this opportunity on morphing
Morgan Creek and and you know in Taoist
philosophy you know water a Creek Morgan
Creek it comes to the obstacle it goes
around it it shapes the obstacle and I
think I think that's where we are in
this in this journey in this alchemists
type journey I think there were gonna be
more right than wrong so we'll see how
this plays out absolutely all right this
is officially the longest podcast we've
ever recorded which I appreciate taking
so much time to do this hopefully
everyone listening to this really enjoys
it and we will we'll have to do it again
in the future when we've got more stuff
to talk about
exactly so much fun thanks for having me
hey everyone
pop here if you liked this episode of
off the chain and want to help us take
crypto to the top of the Apple Spotify
and other podcast charts please do us a
favor and rate review and subscribe to
review simply go to the off-the-chain
homepage scroll down until you see the
five blank stars taking 15 seconds to
fill those stars in and leave a quick
review goes a long way in helping us
take the entire crypto ecosystem to the
top of the charts I appreciate you
listening and see you next time on off
the chain